at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey everybody it's Wednesday evening and
you know what that means it's time to
drink and talk about some crazy [__]
yeah I haven't seen you wear that shirt
in a long time no just I kind of forgot
about it yeah I forgot you had that it's
a Simpsons of Mercy cover band we saw
they were really good yeah they were
like really good sounded like old
Sisters of Mercy they played some of the
new stuff too yeah it's called the
Temple of Mercy sure and even their
little merch was kind of like such as a
mercy step mixed with like the mission
mission UK but anyway
um today
is going to be a UFO case
Tom's favorite is one of my favorite UFO
cases uh just because they're there are
uh police and some Air Force uh
witnesses to it uh now this is in
Belgium of course it's the Belgian UFO
wave
uh we're gonna get into that Jenny dug
up some new stuff
but just on the testimony of the police
I I kind of like bought into this case
and there's a really good uh Unsolved
Mysteries uh from what was it 90 what
year was that 92 92 yeah season four
yeah and it's a little short episode in
there just the way they showed it it was
it seemed to be pretty compelling so I
want to put Jenny on it
see if it if what they showed actually
matches up with the police witness
testimony
um but it's flying triangles and just
the way they described it
man [__] bizarre real bizarre but it
kind of matches up with some of the
other cases for around that time with
the Flying V type things and triangle
type things that were being seen in the
United States kind of like uh UFO over
Illinois I think they had like four or
five different police uh local police
stations or uh no uh what do you call it
yeah not police stations what do you
call police companies saw it
in different counties
and uh I think it actually saw it in the
state next to it I I think and um
kind of remind me of that
and it also kind of reminds me of like
the Phoenix Lights not the flares those
are flares but the fiend the real
Phoenix Lights which is only the one
video of the real one it's just got a
grainy
and it's just
kind of like a v-shape of lights and you
can hear the people going what is that
you know
nothing's big you know it's kind of at a
distance
but um
it's just a case of the era
and uh put Jenny out to see if she can
get down the bottom of it yeah the weird
thing about this is that
um as
compelling as the case seems at first
blush there's really not a [__] ton of
information online about it and I think
maybe that's because I mean I guess
we'll just this will be like a spoiler
alert but the very very famous
photograph pretty much the only yeah
photograph uh that's associated with
this case uh was later discovered to be
a fake uh in 2011 like the person that
made it came forward and said like
showed the media how they made it so it
doesn't mean that the case is fake no no
I'm just saying that um I think there
were some other things too because I I
think um
people are under the impression because
I was telling him this before the show
started I think people are under the
impression
that because it sounds very impressive
it's like you know 143 reports like
initially and like thousands of reports
later but I think that the way that a
lot of like UFO positive let's call it
UFO positive UFO positive sites will
kind of make it seem like all of these
reports came in like as this stuff was
happening but that's actually not the
case like all of the reports were pretty
much after the fact
um and after the first sighting or
whatever had already hit the media and
they were asking for other people's yeah
uh sightings of it so of course like a
lot of people wrote in and was like oh
yeah I saw that [__] too you know what I
mean it's just normal [__] something
happened and then everybody just wanted
to jump in afterwards and make it into
like a fad so it doesn't mean the case
is fake and the same thing with the with
that photograph
the case was already established they
had an investigative team on there
called soaps and they were working with
the Belgian Air Force and everything and
they were just looking at radar data and
in their investigations this photo
emerged from the populace all right
saying hey this is this is a photograph
I took during that night
and they looked at it and they really
couldn't find anything wrong with it but
they so they accepted it
but later on an update on the case is
that some of the investigators that were
in soap saw that photograph they
couldn't debunk it they thought but they
thought it was too good to be true
but they just kind of left it in there
later on it was just a piece of
Styrofoam with some lights on it pretty
much yeah but it
and you know if there's going to be a
photograph of some from that era it
would have been prop most likely from a
distance and it just would have been a
light in the sky that's what it would
have looked like
I mean that cop in Illinois he saw the
thing saw a find a big triangle
hovering over a field right out right up
to his right and he stopped the cop car
and got out went to the trunk got the
Polaroid camera you know the old
instamatic type took a picture of it and
he's got a picture but it's only three
lights and they're blurred because it's
moving so
it's not a question yeah I always kind
of feel like that's sort of the problem
is that you know even if you really did
see a legit UFO
um you know it's better nowadays because
everybody has cell phones until they
have like 4K cameras and stuff like that
so it might be better but when you're
taking it from such a distance it's not
gonna look like Jack [__] it's just
gonna have like a bunch of lights in the
sky it's gonna be like whoop-dee-doo
yeah it doesn't look like anything and
they're blurred
right it's moving he's moving the camera
you know he's moving the camera pressing
the button and it's kind of at a
distance and real low lighting so the
shutters open
and really you know they did a computer
stabilization of the film and it's it's
three lights
it could be anything that's what I mean
three three uh three lights in the
darkness I know that he he took a
picture of it it's just that a Polaroid
camera in low light gives a shitty feel
it gives a shitty image well and you
don't have any contacts there's no kind
of how big it is you don't know how far
away that is it's like it could be an
airplane it could be flares it could be
a million yeah things but you know I
sympathize with the cops he wanted a
picture of it and that was that and he
got a picture but that's you know that's
the only equipment he had and it's just
not it was those cameras were designed
to take a picture of a crime scene on
the Fly you know some dead dude laying
on the ground
and then like a gun next to him you know
that's what they take pictures uh with
that not UFOs it's not a scientific
[__]
high speed camera you know and it was
long before digital cameras
but um
this is still a pretty good case I think
until unless Jenny came up with
something that shatters my image of it
it was it was a fad everybody in Belgium
said oh yeah I saw him I saw it you know
everybody said they saw it they did
just became a fair to lie saying
yourself and it was kind of like the
Phoenix Lights yeah everybody jumped on
a lot of people saw it there were a lot
of people called in on that that's what
all the cool kids are doing but then as
time went on everybody claimed to have
seen it you know that's because it was
cool
that's what I mean I think that's kind
of the issue too is that
people like to jump on jumping on the
bandwagon you know so
that's why it's really good to kind of
go back and look at all the original
yeah you got to go back in time
and then things that things that can't
like you know the debunking of that one
photograph you got to put that in the
investigation degree yeah that got
debunked because the dude that did it
said yeah I did it you know the weird
thing is that I saw like a snippet of an
interview well this one not a snippet it
was about 28 minutes long but it was
um a guy from [__] man who was
interviewing him I thought it was like
the guy from like the New York Post or
something like that and he was
interviewing Nick Pope about this case
and interestingly they brought up the
photograph and like talked about it for
a few minutes but they did not mention
that it was fake which I thought was
kind of interesting and I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure that this was a
post-2011 interview so and after 2011 it
was very widely reported that that that
the kid had come out he wasn't a kid but
he had he was a kid he was 18 when he
faked it so I don't know and I'm I just
thought it was interesting that they
didn't mention that on that interview
you know what I'm saying Trey's saying
it's a cool shirt he wants to see him
now you want this shirt too man but they
were American cover band we have another
American cover band
that covers Sisters of Mercy but it's
all original material and it sounds like
lost Sisters of Mercy bands uh sounds
like a lost Sisters of Mercy album
I think they got two or three of them it
was called the daughters of Bristol yeah
you can find their [__] on YouTube I
wonder if they're still around yeah I
don't know
probably probably not I don't think they
toured I think they just did the [__] at
home yeah because I have one of their
albums in one of their EPS I think yeah
daughter's a Bristol and it sounds just
like classic
late 80s mid 80s Sisters of Mercy but
it's their own stuff their own stuff
they're not covering no it's not covered
but you're like man is that Andrew
Eldridge I thought that was Andrew
Eldridge it sounded you know it sounded
just like them but it's not it's just
some fans that can reproduce that and
they had uh real good
real good music that sounded just like
something off that album you know and
they did other stuff like do some stuff
sound like it came off a vision thing or
flood land they did that kind of stuff
too
um yeah Camp guy says uh it I guess in
belgians he's talking about are they too
busy getting high and drinking hot
chocolate to take pictures yeah I guess
so
I guess so
um and you know because I don't really
know a great deal about Belgium it's
kind of like the Forgotten country but
it's just that little bitty one that's
like is that one little other ones
um they got waffles they got waffles and
they got uh Jean-Claude Van Damme right
he's Belgian didn't he uh yeah I don't
know
I think he is I'll just saying
um let's see where uh there was
something else I wanted to uh yeah Trey
said I had a great book about it about
this case uh I'll have to dig around and
see if we got it yeah and he also
mentioned um there were also around this
time I think like early 90s like you
said was kind of like the Heyday of like
the black triangle black V UFO type
things and um there was also some
sightings in the Hudson Valley
uh in New York the descriptions of the
things were pretty damn cool yeah stuff
that is not was not intuitive in the 90s
like
a craft and it was shooting out two
beams like a laser beam but they would
go out slowly and and then I guess go
down into the trees then they would
retract slowly
so it wasn't a beam as as we know it
and then
a red light underneath the bottom that
would detach and go around and look at
things and then go around and be in
between those beams and then it would go
back up and then they'd be over a church
and it would a little red ball would go
around and look at the church and then
go back up in it and the cops are saying
were like it was like it was measuring
something
and then at one point they were looking
at the triangle there was more than one
of them
and it just had lights in the corner and
the red white lights in the corner and a
red light in the middle and it just
collapsed in on itself and turned into a
ball of light and took off
like it
retreated into a slightly higher
dimension
and then accelerated away no accelerator
accelerated away at a high rate of speed
no Sonic Boom
and there was some radar confirmation in
another part of this wave another part
of this case because this a lot of these
sightings took place over a long period
of time about a year I think on it maybe
two years
um no it was uh just a few months
actually two months okay it was uh the
first sighting was November 29th 1989.
yeah and then uh they went until about
April of 1990. that's like the main
thing being like the end of March 1990
was like the radar thing now recently
the U.S Air Force and the U.S Navy
they've kind of some of these guys have
come forward with some of this weird
reports with radar confirmation
uh really a lot of it off off the coast
of California and it sounds an awful lot
like this
uh same kind of thing
Tic Tac UFOs and things taken off at
highway to speed no Sonic Boom
um
some of the guys that some of the pilots
that gave gave the gun or the uh the
footage because they had camera footage
of it off their damn targeting sensor
camera that they use
I don't know what it's called
it was kind of an old one one that they
were using but they said that the ones
that they're showing on
television
he says that's the shitty footage that
they had a lot better footage and it was
in higher resolution it's just that they
don't they didn't want
the public and say like it for an enemy
armies knowing exactly what their
sensors could pick up so they were
releasing a pretty low resolutions
and also some of that stuff was just
like just not the good sightings so we
don't know what to have
um
but I did remember hearing that some
some of the guys that knew about the
investigations
said that they noticed that as these
objects would move that they would blur
slightly or that they would become kind
of transparent at certain points almost
kind of like
going into slightly different or higher
Dimensions might be part of the
propulsion of these things whatever it
is but but they're starting to say that
they do exist they're start they don't
know what it is or they're claiming they
don't know what it is but they are
seeing them that's what the
the intelligence agencies and the well
which I don't know if I could trust that
but at least the military is saying now
we're seeing these things we don't know
what they are that's all they're saying
well at least they're admitting that
much yeah
and I don't think they do know because I
feel like for a long time it's like they
just pretend it wasn't there like I said
I don't even know if the shit's out
there or whatever but
um you know I I think it's a lot more
honest for them to come forward and be
like yeah we noticed but we don't know
yeah it is
that matched up with
be an ex-military I know how military
machine the military Machine Works the
systems if you're these guys
like uh garden and nuclear
missile facility in England what was
that what was in uh rendersham Forest
yeah yeah if you're with the security
guys
they're kind of like their version of
Air Force infantry you're guarding this
base and you come up with some cockamami
story that yeah we're seeing these
lights and you know you're a damn
Captain okay
and yeah we saw we saw a thing moving it
was blinking it looked like an eye it
looked like stuff melting off of it and
there were things in the sky and it shot
a laser beam if you put in a report like
that
they'd fire you
they would just fire you
if they thought you lied
okay
the fact that they weren't all relieved
and there wasn't a big investigation
tells me that
that the Air Force chain of command knew
that they believed it
so there must have been
some kind of confirmation in terms of
like uh the guy in charge of the base
the Commanding General saw it or heard
about it or got some radar data saying
that yeah there was something that
happened there so this is what they saw
and this is that what their report is so
I'm not going to punish them
because if they thought it was a false
report they'd fire you
what are these dudes doing they're
getting out there [__] high out in
the middle of the day they're supposed
to be guarding nuclear weapons and
you're coming up with this [__] crazy
[__] they'd get all relieved they would
relieve them of Duty well you know and
rightfully so if you're just out there
making [__] up that's uh you know so
what that tells me is that they were
believed
but they wanted to sweep it underneath
the rug
now not every aspect of that Reynolds
from forest tale I don't believe every
aspect of it because some dudes the
stories got Wilder and Wilder as time
went on
because they were getting a lot of
attention in the media see that's kind
of the problem that's why I think cases
like this anything having to do with
anything extraordinary like UFO
sightings ghost settings whatever the
[__] it is you always kind of have to go
back to the originals what do they
originally saying because I kind of feel
like well and this happens to regular
people too just the more times you tell
a story and even if it's nothing
extraordinary like it's just something
that happened in your past the more
times you retell it the more likely you
are to you know embellish the details
and stuff like that so and especially
and I think that's exacerbated greatly
when you're getting a lot of media
attention so it's like always going to
be I mean you don't want to go fan base
yeah you don't want to go on TV and just
tell this boring ass story like oh I saw
a light in the sky at the end it's like
you want to like make up some [__] you
know what I mean and I don't even know
if they do it I mean I'm sure some of
them do it deliberately like exactly
like knowing what they're doing but I
think it's almost kind of like a natural
progression you just kind of add little
details yeah you just keep and then like
the more you add the details and the
more you repeat it the more you remember
it like that because human memory is not
real uh it's not real faithful of what
actually happened part of it you know I
think his name was Holt you guys can
drop the the names of the guys I don't
remember what the captain's name was I
think his name was Holt and then the uh
they had an NCO that said he saw a
little triangle probe type craft
on the ground with a bunch of
hieroglyphs on there which some of the
other guys didn't know that didn't
happen all right what seems to happen in
the render shim case is that I think
it's something actually did happen but
then those dudes started to go on tour
all right and they're going to all these
UFO conventions yeah and the crowd
wanted to know more and more and they're
pushing them to say more and more and
every time this every time that they
would add a little bit more to the story
they get rewarded with right adulation
and fame so they they were being
encouraged by their fan base to start
fabricating stuff which tainted the case
you got to go to you you gotta stick
with the original story hit I think
halts tape of what he was seeing
um yeah as as close to the original
incident as you can get like because
then it hasn't been tainted by memory
it's like still fresh in their memory
they haven't like had a chance to kind
of like you know construct a different
memory in their minds because that is
that that is what happens yeah as time
goes by and the original story really of
the rendelson forest case that when you
take it back to what originally was is
they were out there and there was lights
in the sky some kind of weird craft in
the sky there's more than one of them
and while they were out there in the
field it shot a damn beam of light like
a laser beam down at their feet under
the ground and the captain saw that
and then he saw it move across the field
and then it just [__] winked out and
disappeared
um he said it looked like it had molten
lava coming off of it but you know when
you're looking at something especially I
don't know if he was looking at it
through binoculars at night uh or if he
was just trying to focus in real hard on
something at night which you know I've
been in that situation I could tell you
some stories in the military your how
your eyes can deceive you especially if
you're in a really charged emotional
state you saw some there was a time
where I was watching an Airfield as part
of my job and a [__] military
aircraft I saw it land and there wasn't
supposed to be the military aircraft I
[__] jumped out of my skin because I
was writing a letter at the time so it
shocked me and they asked me what kind
of com aircraft it was and I would say
oh it was a
it was a swept Wing Jet
and it was camouflaged
well when we went down there to check it
it was not a swap Wing Jet it was a
[__] C-130 cargo plane it was painted
Orange
yeah so the fact that you thought it was
camouflage yeah and it was Orange right
and it was a completely different kind
of plate yeah and the Sarge's assessment
what you know it was kind of and I was
just saying I think that's what it was
it was a military aircraft and it was in
some kind of a
painting configuration I think
camouflage you know I didn't commit to
that it's just that I saw it so briefly
and I'd shot I've got so shocked by it
or startled by it because I wasn't
supposed to be up there watching that
kind of [__]
I saw it as a swept Wing Jet I in my
mind it looked like a b a B1 bomber you
remember the b-1b yeah ultrasonic bomber
from the fight that's what I that's what
I thought it was and that it was
in almost like a World War II luftwaffe
[__]
camouflage
gray with green spray paint [__]
squiggles and [__] all over what were
you writing the letter about did that
happen writing my girlfriend at the time
I don't remember what it was oh okay
listen to the music and I was in a
[__] Watch Tower no watching the
[__] Egyptian Airfield and that [__]
came down
and it went behind a building went
behind a hanger
and I knew it was bad because it would I
recognized it as a military aircraft
and with a strange paint job and my
subconscious said yeah it was a b-1b in
a [__] camouflage go to war [__]
paint Scheme no it was a [__] car
military cargo plane painted orange
because it was which is it wasn't
military it was ex-military
under contract and they turned it into a
damn car just a civilian cargo plane see
and this is why I'm always really really
skeptical about anything whose entire
uh veracity rests on witness testimony
yeah because nothing against anybody
human brains are amazing but they are
also very very fallible very fast now
the mitigating circumstances time
in this case these cops watched this
[__] for up to a half hour
and man during that time you can really
get some calm reasoning and cool
reflection and go okay I know what I'm
looking at because that's enough time
it's only happened to me when I only had
seconds
you know
I'm gonna have seconds to see it and to
figure out what it was that's when you
make the error so I give a little bit of
credibility to to certain aspects of the
Belgian wave sightings especially when
it's the Belgian cops the Jean Damaris
them guys
Dave tell a wild story and it took time
they said they were watching it for a
half hour doing stuff
and what it's doing
is not civilian or military it almost
looks like scientific or recreational
whatever this was
crafts going around and looking at
churches and [__]
and then over the water
over over Lakes
sending little red balls of light down
into the water
or they thought it was going to the
water and then it would come back up
and you know my [__] mind is like
what's it doing with that water
is it getting going down there and
capturing fish as samples and what is it
doing because if you went to an alien
crack Alien Planet when you want to like
take some wildlife
yeah
so I wouldn't know well I mean pictures
I'd be like let's go look at the fish
look at that fish
you know you just look at the squirrel
because they said that the the red ball
light would go into the trees
and then it would go back up wouldn't it
be funny if like the aliens came here
and they found squirrels a lot more
interesting than humans yeah what did it
do did it steal a squirrel you know what
happened I want to know more like look
at these little buddies yeah
[Laughter]
it's like that gives you an idea for a
short story actually I should probably
write something like we'll be laugh at
it no it's like I laugh because it's
like that sounds kind of like something
that they would do well yeah because
humans are really up themselves and they
kind of think like we're the most
awesome thing ever but it's like you
know from an objective like alien
standpoint we might not be not that
interesting at all like from their
perspective well well they would
you would think that even if they were
just Ai and not biological
they would know you you probably
shouldn't be stealing an entire human
you know what I mean
yeah but you can take a squirrel then no
one will notice nobody will notice it
squirrels won't report it to them and
they're close enough I mean to be honest
well now you got something to show of
others of your species because
squirrel's like where the [__] am I what
am I doing here
where's my tree well they might put it
back too they might take it and then
record it in some way record images and
then put it back you don't know
and now I'm kind of wondering like how
his little squirrel friends are like
because it's like man Dave got taken
away last time I was like where the [__]
did he go and then he came back and he's
like you guys you guys like it's like I
don't know I humanize all day I would I
would think that in a super
technological
species came they would take samples and
make intricate
analog and digital recordings of the
animal everything about it and they'd
probably put it back as because they
would probably have some kind of a
philosophy of not permanently disturbing
anything
because then that would be like
[__] up with the w [__] up [__]
with the biosphere yeah you know what I
mean so they probably probably going
down and grabbing Little Creatures
insects and stuff and
recording the entire experience and the
little gestalta of it what they look
like what they smell like to them what
they what they're made of and how they
work and then record it every intricate
detail thing and then put it back it's
probably [__] like that
and they probably do it regularly
and it's probably not a big deal it's
just a standard operating procedure that
they do
And Justice For Me says eyewitness
testimony is one of the top claims of
Christianity uh faulty yeah that's
that's the thing like I said you can't
and I'm not like casting aspersions on
anybody that has like seen some [__]
because obviously but I really need some
other
more objective evidence
gesture say so is not gonna you're
making a mistake though you're you're
looking at those old those old books and
they were from day one written as
religious
religious material there's no eyewitness
testimony in there at all well some of
it claims to be no look looked closely
like because it says that the three
widows at the tomb they saw the angel
and they ran away at a fright and told
no one well they told no one how the
[__] is it in the book right so no it's
a movie
but like I'm just saying yeah I mean
that whole thing but that kind of like
goes with Ed I mean anything UFO
sightings ghost sightings like crime
um that's why I don't think you should
ever let convict a person just on oh
yeah that's the [__] that did
whatever because
they had this little white chick put
this black dude [__] prison for like
10 15 years for rape that happens a lot
and then it comes out later the DNA
disproved it and it was another one
another dude came up hot with that DNA
and she goes yeah yeah it was him it
wasn't the other one it was that one and
she went and [__] got that other guy
out of prison he wouldn't want to let
the first guy out
they're just always like yeah but you
still might have done something yeah
like seriously I didn't do anything that
dude that dude was in there for like
about 10 years and she fought hard to
get to get him back out of there that
she had misidentified him became friends
with him [__] I can't I can't imagine
yeah and when he got out she was hugging
him [__] I'm sorry you know that kind
of [__] you know if I can she I don't
know if Sorry's gonna cut it though I
will here's the thing she thought it was
him right that's the thing and you can't
like [__] on her too hard because you
know it was probably it was a very
traumatic experience mine was [__] up
and you know I get that your you know
your brain isn't making the very good
like associations it was like you did
the cops showed her right
so she goes yeah that's him
you know it wasn't him it was another
guy so maybe it's the cop's fault it was
just the way that [__] particular
case went down they showed him a dude
and he said this guy she's like yeah
that's him it wasn't that's I mean
that's why I'm kind of I'm really glad
that we have DNA now because at least
now we can be like yeah that wasn't the
[__] that it was just like I
don't care because and you know and
especially if you've been the victim of
a crime
um but like I said you're not I mean
understandably you're not in the best
frame of mind to be like oh what did the
dude look like and [__] like that like
if some dude just jumped out of the
bushes and like attacked me and [__]
like that I don't know what that
[__] looks like well blew my
mind is that they [__] that the the
one dude came up hot it was his DNA they
locked his ass up and they left the
other guy locked up too
she's like what about yeah man let him
out well yeah they didn't really want to
let that guy out that's what I mean
that's like so weird to me because it's
like well it's not weird I know why they
do it but it's like um once somebody
gets convicted of something like later
on they have evidence they're like okay
that dude absolutely did not do that
then they're like yeah but he's already
in jail though like he must let him out
yeah so it's almost like he's become
tainted yeah yeah even though they put
him in they're erroneously to start with
but it's like once you're already in
jail it's like so much easier yeah it
would just be like oh well you must be a
criminal or you wouldn't have got caught
in the first place or you wouldn't have
yet I guess it was a dude the cops
wanted the cops wanted locked up for
something that they thought he was did
that [__] and it was just maybe a local
Troublemaker or something they just
wanted that dude locked up they wanted
it to be him or they were just or they
just or they didn't like him or they
just were too lazy to like we don't even
want to do the paperwork I think all the
above who knows
but yeah I've noticed that because like
I said I've written a lot of about a lot
of True Crime cases where you know
somebody gets convicted or put in prison
for a certain thing and then later on
like years later they find out through
DNA usually it's like oh that wasn't
them
um they're usually real reluctant yeah
you would think like the same day yeah
no yeah sorry the whole process and like
if it took her like a year or so to get
him out give him a bunch of money too
because it's like they [__] up their
whole life and it's like bro I didn't do
anything it was just the wrong place at
the wrong time you like picked me up and
that's [__] up I honestly I'm more of
the opinion I would rather
I know this is
I don't know this is kind of like I
would rather like somebody that did some
[__] go free than an innocent person
that did nothing going to prison because
it's like that like anybody that could
happen to anybody like you could just be
in the wrong place at the wrong time
somebody misidentifies you for whatever
reason and then suddenly you get slammed
in prison for 10 20 years your whole
entire life is ruined and you didn't do
jack [__] and I don't really think that
should happen to anybody you know what I
mean so I think we should always err on
the side of yeah the system's broken
especially in certain States certain you
know not every state has the same legal
system but some of these legal systems
they're [__] well it's almost like if
you get arrested for something like
everybody just assumes right everybody
just assumes oh well you might even if
you didn't do that you must have done
something some of these states because
how did you get arrested and it's like
some of these states uh one of the worst
ones traditionally was was Louisiana
because it was Napoleonic law and it was
the American version of [__]
Napoleonic law and you're dealing with
[__] Cajuns are crazy as [__] I can
pull my some of my Cajun cousins in here
and he'd be like what the [__] no if you
got accused of you just got accused of a
crime they had like a 90 95 [__]
conviction rate just being accused
yeah well you must have done something
so yeah you could be accused and
convicted with no evidence
well that's how yeah I mean Louisiana is
probably bad but it happens everywhere
yeah that happens everywhere sadly like
I said I think we should always err on
the side of yeah it's not great letting
guilty people run free I'm not saying we
should do that I'm just saying that it's
much better
it's probably better to err on the side
of this person didn't do [__] yeah if in
Louisiana if a woman said that if a
woman says
you abducted her raped her and killed
her wait she says that yeah she said
yeah yeah that's how ridiculous it is
there's doesn't have to be any evidence
just an accusation oh you're gonna do
[__] life
because it's a life sentence for [__]
um in Louisiana it was a life sentence
for uh kidnapping
so just on the word of a single person
with no Witnesses no nothing
it's too much damn power
a woman just says yeah he he kidnapped
me
you're going you're going you're going
you're going to prison
well like I said that's why you know and
I'm not and I'm not saying that we
shouldn't believe people when they yeah
and stuff like that but you need
something else to back that up because
as we were saying earlier and I know
we've drifted far afield from UFOs but
it's kind of the same thing because
witness testimony
I hate to say but it doesn't really mean
jack [__] like if somebody just comes
out and says this happened if there's
not any corroborating evidence if
there's not any backup evidence then I
don't know I'm gonna say witness
testimony is important
especially if it's if the testimony has
something to do with something that took
over took place over a long period of
time
whereas mostly fallible is when it's
you're talking about something that's
has happened in in seconds
okay yeah because like I said there's
not time you're not in the best frame of
mind to like you know create good right
right that's the difference so I'm going
to give this case in some in some cases
pretty good amount of weight because the
cops said they were they'd watched it
for a half hour
you know so
it's hard to be mistaken for a half hour
it's just this yeah
well because you have time to like sit
there and think about analyze and go
what am I really looking at rather than
like I said you know it you know I'm a
true crime person so it's like somebody
busting your house and suddenly is
waving a gun in your face you don't have
much time you're not going to really
have much time to like look at the shape
of that dude's ears or whatever you know
really identify them too much right
which in a way like kind of amazes me
every time I see like Witnesses and they
uh you know give the um the police a
description and they're able to get a um
you know the the sketch and everything
and then like later on they catch the
actual person and it looks like the
sketch I'm always kind of like man that
person's a [__] hero because they
actually described what the person
looked like enough that the sketch like
actually resembled them because it's
like I'm not actually sure if I would be
able to do that yeah like if if it was
like a really stressful situation I
don't really look at people all that
closely to be honest with you we're
trying not to look at you at the best of
times yeah it's like I'm trying not to
look at people most of the time so it's
like
um I it kind of scares me sometimes
because I'm like [__] man what if I was
somewhere and like something bad really
happened and I was like in a position
where I had to identify somebody that
had done some [__] up [__] and I was
like I would I'm like they look kind of
like a blur it's like I don't know it
was a dude yeah with arms and a head
like that's pretty much as much as I'd
be able to give you so I would probably
be no help in that situation because I
don't really look at people like that
uh Ben says you might as well draw a
stickman figure in most cases yeah and
like I said I think you you do kind of
see the cases where the the sketch
actually looked like the person that
they caught later and that they proved
that that's who it was and I'm always
like impressed by that because [__] I
can't imagine being put in a position
where I'm just like what shape was his
nose I'm like I don't [__] know it
was nose shaped yeah
you know what I mean it's like I don't I
don't even know what you're talking
about so
um and justice for me said since we
reside in Florida do you know if release
prisoners can sue and be awarded
compensatory damages very rare I don't
know but it's like I would hope that
they would because seriously if you were
innocently and people who are innocent
and you're wrongly accused and you're
put in prison for like 10 years they
should absolutely give you at least
enough money to cover like
lost wages for that time plus like some
extra [__] for I don't know about this
statement Most states that ends up
having political repercussions depends
on whether or not judges or elected you
know they could come back on a judge and
a lot a lot of times what they'll do is
you know they'll say no you can't sue us
you know they have certain kinds of
immunity what do they call it uh there's
a term for it
a lot of times in the Americans okay
just look
just look at the federal government
state government when's the last time
any of those people have ever been sent
to prison
for [__] crimes that they've
committed never they steal money and
they lie they they do whatever well the
more money yeah you're gonna suffer any
repercussions
for the little people yeah they they you
can't really hurt them you know what I
mean but then they're astounded when
like uh leaders from other countries
don't go to jail for what they do
because a lot of arrogance in the
American system they think their [__]
don't stink
yeah that's really what it is [__] you
[__] stole all that goddamn money and
you lied and you did you need to go to
jail no oh no not us I'm a governor well
I mean
they're criminals everybody
rationalizes and justifies their own bad
behavior yeah that's kind of why
you know not everybody's shitty is it
honestly like most people are okay yeah
but the thing about it is that if you do
really shitty stuff
none of those people are thinking hey
I'm a [__] super villain or I'm a bad
person like 99 of those people don't
think that they always have reasons for
what they're doing or they have some
justification for what they're doing
which is why it's so hard to
kind of get them to realize it because
they don't really think they're the bad
guy even if they very clearly are the
bad guys everybody thinks they're the
good guy everybody thinks there's the
hero like should George Bush have gone
to [__] prison for that [__]
weapons of mass destruction [__] and all
those millions of Iraqis that got killed
should you I think so yeah okay now
should Obama should Barack Obama got
[__] gotten relieved or gone to
prison for all those damn weddings that
they drone striked in Afghanistan yeah
probably should have this should have
been we had no business being in
Afghanistan telling those people how to
live blowing them up because of their
religious beliefs this is exactly what
was going on and in making it's all
about making money more than anything
else we didn't change that place and
like I said The more money in power that
you have the more [__] you can get away
yes you know what I mean so which is sad
but that's just the way the whole
[__] world works and always has as
far as I know it's a jungle out there
people these governments are just other
animals in the jungle and there's a lot
of animals out in the jungles the
corporations are animals in the jungle
you're in a jungle nothing's nothing's
we got to get to UFOs though let's get
to uh grandpa says the weakest evidence
in a case is always When a Stranger has
to identify another stranger yeah
exactly memories of how someone looked
how they dressed Etc Notorious being
inaccurate yeah and like I say I'm I'm
telling you right now if I was the
victim of a crime I'm gonna be
absolutely no help I'm not going to
remember anything about the [__] because
I don't even look at people in the best
of [__] circumstances so much less be
able to remember something in like a
high stress situation like that so I'm
I'm very comfortable with the fact that
I that my memory is not
um accurate
because I know how memory works yeah and
I know how psychology works and I'm okay
with that you know a lot of people
aren't they think they have like really
good memories or it's like and that's
where you get into trouble the
overconfidence I am not overcome I'm
under confident I probably remember [__]
better than I think I do but I'm just
gonna err on the side of like not being
not being all that confident about like
my memory abilities so I'm just gonna
say look
I I don't remember what the dude looked
like okay I'm not even gonna tell you
anything because you're gonna pick up a
wrong dude and then I'm gonna be
responsible for that and I'm gonna be
responsible for that you know yeah Camp
guys going we even got a war going in
Ukraine yeah we picked that fight
planned it out [__] 10 years ago
overthrew their government 10 years ago
and put Nazis in charge now they got
their now you got the Democrats
supporting supporting Nazis the azov are
a bunch of Nazis they [__] what's his
name [__] Bandera they're bandaristas
but you won't hear that on the news
because they don't want to tell you that
they're making money over there
and they own property over there
yeah they need to be punished man for
what they're doing this is an evil
empire and I'm so glad that the internet
has exposed these people for what they
were I joined up the US Army to go to
war for this [__] I can't believe it
I [__] can't believe it but it's true
we're bad all right it's an Empire it's
got like the Roman Empire man it's
collapsing like the Roman Empire too
yeah well you know yeah you mean duh in
the 90s you wouldn't have known I knew
in the 90s I don't know where you were I
believe it's television I believe CNN
and MSNBC and I didn't have MSNBC yet
until later and [__] uh NBC and I
believe the corporate news propaganda
media I believed it I thought we were
the good guys now we're the Bad Guys
we've been the bad guys yeah yeah
all the way back to the 1800s the [__]
that we did the [__] banana Wars to
Central and South America news flash
been going on forever just that I didn't
really know that at [__] 1920. you
know you don't really know grafter said
you can only hope some DNA gets left at
the scene that's accurate to one in a
billion yeah honestly I would rather
you know I'd rather trust DNA it's not
it's not susceptible to uh being [__]
with the way human memory is and that's
just human memory is just that's just
the way it works it's fallible
everyone's like that it's not you know a
judgment or anything like that but it's
just not real accurate so I would rather
like DNA is you know 99.9 accurate so
I'd rather go with that if you don't
have any DNA if all you have is witness
testimony then
I'm just gonna say err on the side of
Lake not Victor said Jenny you could
commit crimes because they'd be looking
for a big boobed woman in her early 30s
yeah
sexy big boob woman in the 30s
yeah well and I and I can kind of change
because I got lots of wigs all kind of
stuff so you know what I mean I could do
I could be like a master criminal yeah
don't think I haven't thought about it
yeah I've thought about a lot of times I
was like maybe I could rob a bank
don't have to we got money coming
Jenny starts work starts work Friday
yeah yeah oh so yeah that was another
thing I wanted to say well I'll probably
let's get started yeah before it well
before we get started getting started
now that we're like now that we're
almost an hour in yeah now we're in um
yeah so I got a job like a full-time
Nightfall eight to five actually uh and
it's in Daytona so that's gonna be an
hour or 50 minutes each way like uh
commute which you know fine I grew up in
Daytona so it's worth it good job yeah
yeah and um so I'm gonna go there on
Friday and like Shadow the guy so I can
learn how to do the stuff and everything
like that so actually Friday we're not
going to be able to do the Sidetrack
show because I'm gonna be at work all
day and then my sister is coming down
for the weekend for uh from Atlanta and
I'm gonna go to my brother's house
because my brother lives in Daytona and
I'm gonna hang out with my sister and my
brother on Friday night so we will
probably move the Sidetrack show to
Saturday yeah I think I might go to the
biker bar Friday night then
I was thinking you probably would
either that'd ride down to [__] don't
don't get any social diseases no
no not any cute girls over there I tell
you I would never cheat on you what are
you talking about
I'm just teasing you I know not with
that not without having you in the mix
[Laughter]
and uh no yeah he's like it's only fun
if you're there
although we'll see uh we'll see where so
you'll be back late that night though
right
yeah I mean I imagine it'll probably be
because it's about like I said it's
about a 50 minute drive what time do you
think our house what time you thinking
back for uh Friday I don't know it
depends on what they want to do okay
before midnight probably I imagine okay
before midnight yeah I don't really want
to say it all night okay you know what I
mean I might check I might check out
Oasis at night I've never really been on
a Friday night because like I said we're
not gonna go anywhere we're just gonna
hang out at my brother's house right in
Daytona like my brother and his wife and
because my sister is staying there over
the weekend they're gonna go like
they're all gonna go to Epcot but I
can't afford a good Epcot like on
Saturday so I was like well I'll come
see you Friday night then because I have
to be in Daytona anyway because you know
I'm going to be working that day
uh grantor says live stream from The
Oasis what's the new job uh it's graphic
design it's a graphic design job that's
what she does yeah it's it's what I do
yeah it's good money so we're gonna do
the show and this so that it'll help out
man we got to put a new roof on this
place 15 grand
yeah
um dealing with banks to try to get the
uh because the financing that they have
I don't really like the [__] APR I
want to see if I could get some better
[__] through the [__] bags for me
even join a credit union we'll see what
it is I got some [__] up here
but um I don't
you know that you know the Homestead Act
stuff and all that veteran stuff it
didn't save us as nearly as much money
as I thought it was going to be it never
does no
always assume that you're gonna get
[__] harder than you thought you were
gonna get [__] harder and not in the
fun way save us maybe like [__]
because look I've been poor my whole
entire life so I just assume well I'm
just gonna be broke forever and I'm just
saying yeah just maybe a thousand bucks
a year well you know that's better than
nothing yeah 70 80 bucks a month maybe
thank you grafters one one shingle taken
care of thank you very much thank you
thank you very much yeah super chats are
active and uh we also have super thanks
a new feature that if you're watching
this program recorded you can put some
money in the tip jar because the program
because we got all different kinds of
time zones happening also we have
memberships which if you for some reason
you don't like patreon or something like
that and uh we also have a membership on
YouTube it's 2.99 and what I will do is
I'm gonna do like you know the polls
that I do on patreon if you're a patron
you know that I do polls like for you
know what the topic is going to be and
like with the movies we're going to talk
about stuff like that so I will also
start posting those in a members only uh
tab on YouTube like in the community tab
so I will do that as well uh and it'll
probably go up on Friday or Saturday I
can't remember now granther says 50
minutes each way yikes
um not the longest commute I've ever
done to be honest um it's an easy
commute it's not in traffic yeah the
thing about Orlando in general is that
pretty much anywhere you want to go even
if it's not that far is gonna take you
at least half an hour uh because of
especially if you have to get on I-4
because during the day that [__] is just
like a big giant parking lot so
um and honestly for a long time for many
years when I first moved to Orlando I
was working in Daytona still like I was
working night shift so it was usually
like three or four in the morning but it
was like an hour drive like from where I
live to so it's not really that big a
deal I didn't um an interview yesterday
like at a place that was closer
um in the I think it was only 20 miles
something like that
um and it was it seemed cool but I was
just kind of like well I already got
this other job offer and I really kind
of need a job so you need to work quick
right and you still wanted him and ha
they're like we'll call you in a couple
weeks after we've seen a bunch of people
yeah he's like oh we got all these other
interviews and blah blah and I was just
like look I just can't really wait yeah
um you know it would have been cooler
like if I could have got that just
because it was closer but I was like you
know I I need money so I can't like
really dick around and that first place
was jacked to have her I mean they
called her right back they called me the
same day like a couple of hours we need
you yeah it's like please you know what
I mean so so I want to be in a place
like that yeah and like I said it seemed
like super cool and like really chill
and like the people seemed really nice
and yeah so I'm into it and it's very
casual which I love and it's a dog
friendly office which I also love
everybody had their dogs there's dogs
have fun make some money yeah yeah so
and like I said it's far but I grew up
in Daytona I'm very familiar with that
area I still have family there so you
know some bad [__] happens when I'm in
Daytona my brother lives there my dad
lives there like I still gotta get you a
better car in a couple of months yeah
that's the first thing I have to save up
for because my [__] car is so old
yeah uh but yeah all right uh retro
reaction said congratulations on the job
thank you very much yeah it'll keep the
show going I'm looking forward to it
again like I said we might have to for
the live streams we will probably have
to push them a little bit later
um because I wouldn't I won't get off
till five and then like it'll take me
almost an hour to get home and then so
we might push the shows back to seven
maybe instead of six
yeah we'll figure out what we're gonna
do we got we have we have patrons and
subscribers so we really you know we we
can't go anywhere
people are paying to be a part of the
show so well and I want to keep doing
the show and like I said I want to do
um I still want to do my recorded
reviews my book reviews my movie reviews
like my scare Salon stuff my crime
Memorial stuff I will probably have to
like do less
um you know maybe I can just do one a
week or something like that instead of
the million that I was doing but you
know I still want to do them because I
have fun doing these Victor Garcia says
that later is better
I think it is too yeah
so yeah we may be like seven or seven
thirty or something like that like
Eastern Standard Time James Perkins says
that we are very entertained thank you
very much thank you yeah
yeah Victor said when I was watching
your show in Europe it was perfect it
was like midnight
yeah so that's what we'll do we'll
figure it out like you know like I said
I'm going Friday for training uh because
you know they I have to go there and
fill out the stuff they have to do a
background check and all that kind of
stuff so
and uh you know she called me back and
said hey do you want to since you're
coming anyway do you want to like just
work all that day and like shatter the
person and like learn how to do it and I
was like sure why not so
you know getting paid for that day so
that's good and then whenever they want
me to because I'm replacing
um another girl that worked there who I
met who was also very nice so
we'll see how it goes so hopefully like
I said get some [__] but you know
it's full time so I won't be home until
probably like six in the six in the
afternoon Richard Brown said Jenny just
write a best-selling horror Blockbuster
novel
um I'm working on it it's just really
slow I actually did apply I don't know
if I want to jinx it but I did apply for
a writing Grant
um but I won't know if I got it until
May I'm not counting on it because I
imagine a lot of people are probably
applying for it but we'll see how that
goes it's not enough money to like keep
me going and like not have to have a job
but it's a it's you know it's a
significant chunk of change and because
I would really like to get the novel
that I started on which I have probably
about a quarter written I would really
like that done this year
you know what I mean
grandpa says uh grandther recently got a
full-time job after three years of
retirement work sucks but having more
money is dope as fun yeah that's yeah
that's what I figured it's like look
I've been freelancing since 2016 and I
really do like you know working from my
home office it's pretty cool like that I
can just do but it really blows not
having enough money to do anything
because I was telling Tom I was like
look it's like yeah it's cool that I can
stay home and work but it's like I don't
have any money anymore so it's like I
can't I can't do anything I can't like
go on vacation if I can't I can't even
go eat at a restaurant if I want because
I don't have any money you know what I
mean so it's just kind of like
you just gotta like change it out and
and you know I I just need something
that's kind of more steady and that it's
going to have money coming in and then I
can still do this and that would be like
a little bit extra money too and I'm
just kind of like looking forward to
getting back and I'm not looking forward
to the drive but I've done it before and
it's really not that big a deal I'll
feel better when I can save up enough to
get a new car because I am kind of
worried about my old car my old car is
like very reliable I'm not saying that
but it is very old so
eventually I'm gonna have to make some
money too
right right up the road they got a
nursery I was you know what I was before
I got the call back I was thinking about
maybe I should go up there and do that
because that's like within walking
distance yeah it's right over there
there's a nursery over there they'll pay
you by the piece moving things around
[__] pot and things and moving pot of
plants around yeah it's a huge Nursery
yeah it's a big old Nursery it's like
literally you can walk there it's just
right they have like uh like the
mentally handicapped people working in
there
you know I mean they'll bring them a
whole bus load and they'll do it they
get paid
yeah they just pay you every day but
what I would do is I'd use it as
partially as my workout
yeah there you go yeah you [__] bump
steroids and go down there move [__]
move [__] see how it is see how much you
actually make there
you know you might make 100 bucks a day
I don't know but there's no schedule see
that's a good thing you're like I'm
gonna make some money just go down there
yeah you just go down there and like do
whatever they need okay you buy the
piece work I told you I thought about
doing that too I even thought about
walking over to [__] Dollar General
and asking them if they needed any help
yeah that's a good that's a good idea
it's right there yeah because I was like
well I could walk to it so if my car
broke down like I you know it's still
right yeah I mean if I were to could
just pick up another like two 300 bucks
a week that would make a big difference
on me that's what I mean because you
know [__]
I mean Dollar General is probably not
that I figured it's I've worked retail
before that's easy man stalking that
[__] the liquor store is looking for
somebody
oh that's right I forgot about that yeah
I mean you're probably you can't walk to
that you got to drive too because it's
probably like a mile or something like
up there yeah you could go to a
motorcycle at the liquor store yeah
that's true yeah that might be a fun job
just get there if I could sell a booze
yeah I can't imagine it's like all that
crowded easy yeah easy I'm running a
register really in stock and things
that's all it is yeah and I've done that
before like I said yeah I never worked
at a liquor store but I worked it well I
worked at a liquor distributor I worked
at a record store before yeah which is
kind of the same thing like a retail
time type thing all right there's lots
of jobs here just not most of them are
not full-time they're they're these
little side gigs
they're gonna give you a couple days I
even got into I applied to do doordash
as well but there's not really a lot of
call for doordash in this area that's
kind of the shitty thing isn't that
Urban we're kind of out in the middle of
nowhere so country work out here right
so you'd have to like kind of do because
there's not like a lot within you know I
don't want to get back in a horse
industry you know if I can work in horse
farms and [__] it's hot work it's not
real rewarding it's just more not it's
not it's not a rewarding monetarily yeah
it's rewarding in other ways it's
slower pace you're dealing with animals
the people are pretty cool but it's just
the weather gets to you it's either hot
or real cold in the [__] hours you
got to wake up early to [__] feed the
horses and [__] let horses out and if
I can do all kinds of [__] but there's
[__] that I could do in some of these
local farms here yeah there's lots of
farmers around here I worked at one up
there [__] 10 years ago
Jones Perkins said I'm just imagining
walking into a Dollar General and seeing
Jenny behind the counter yeah well the
thing about our Dollar General here
that's like just next door to our house
is that that's our version of 7-Eleven
it's right here I mean it's right there
like yeah you can just like walk to it's
right outside the neighborhood yeah
um it's super handy because they have
everything they got good staff they're
friendly yeah they're always local hey
what's up man you know if I can do what
I'll talk about well the nice thing
about it is that most of their [__] is
they have a um I mean as small as the
store is they have a self-checkout yeah
so it's like and most people just do the
self-checkout and leave so they don't
really need somebody like working the
register they're mostly stocking they're
getting stock and making sure nobody's
stealing right that's pretty much all
they're doing because most people just
use the self-check I always use the
self-checkout because I don't like to
deal with people but you know yeah Trey
said I worked at a liquor store once it
was a breeze of a job yeah it
does actually it's right next to Publix
it's a nice place too
yeah it's it's I mean it's real small
but it's like yeah it's just you always
gotta dab Help Wanted sign out front and
it's it's it's young ladies working
there and they don't look real jacked
about being there and I think it's the
problems that ours they're not getting
enough hours but a retired guy like me
doesn't give a [__] about the hours
yeah to you it's just extra money it's
just extra money right
I mean not like you're right not losers
like me that actually like need the
money I need as many hours as possible
so you know what I mean I just got to
pay off my [__] credit card [__]
well I have to pay off all seven or
eight of my credit cards look here we're
having a good time we're getting
sidetracked we got to get about the UFOs
man I mean we talked about we talked
about UFOs we're going to talk about
this case okay we still haven't even
cracked it we're right there well no I
haven't even scrolled down I haven't
even cracked it we got so much shell
left it's not even [__] funny and we
gotta oh and there's a lot of people in
there I'm sure everybody will be excited
because we're okay so we're gonna get
into this [__] I'm a [__]
witness a paranormal stuff I'm a
Paranormal Witness
okay they had a whole
series based upon me
parallel witness remember that just
kidding yeah
I don't know what you're talking about
but uh
saw Poltergeist had an out-of-body
experience near-death experience
dreaming true a lot of paranormal [__] a
lot of military and police guys [__]
have this because
just look at Terence pops he's exf guy
he was in charge of Abu garib prison
after that Scandal happened and he saw
some [__] at Abu garib was [__] bad
over in Iraq
um he he says oh yeah that place is
[__] haunted as [__]
it was like being an Auschwitz I mean
they tortured people and [__] did
sexual [__] torture on on [__]
prisoners there had them all buried
bones coming up out of the ground
[__] whatever just bearing them out
in the back Lots it was like working at
Auschwitz it was like that level
Saddam did all kinds of [__] weird
[__] in those prisons
and his uh his intelligence agents
agents so um
you would think that
you would think that guys that are
military wouldn't have a [__] belief
in things that are paranormal but we do
we had weird experiences a lot of guys
and I had another theory I talked about
later of why
because it's an animal
ability not so much
well
those jobs are very much high stress
yeah jobs
um and they're very much based around
uncertainty you don't really and right
and you don't really know like you know
you go into like if you're a cop for
example you walk into a situation you
don't know how the shit's gonna go so
sometimes the more uncertainty surrounds
a situation the more you're gonna try
and
you know
um I don't know like kind of control
thing or make yourself feel better about
I have some control over this situation
yeah and sometimes that means you know
believing it like oh I have a lucky
something or rather like a lucky
necklace or some [__] like that because
it makes you feel like more confident
because you're going into a situation
you don't know how that shit's gonna go
now military and police guys
have a very high
have a very high probability of seeing
something like a UFO
they're up at strange hours they're
Alert in the middle of the night
they're in sometimes aircraft or cars
and they're coming in so they're going
to be the ones at four o'clock in the
morning or have their eyes open if
something appears they're going to be
the ones that see it because they're
going to be watching out for others
right they're watching obviously right
and this is what happens cops and
Military guys
see [__] UFOs
all right
and the militaries believe it now or
they're admitting that they believe it
it doesn't make sense that we're the
only life in the damn Galaxy
it doesn't make this it doesn't make
sense that we're the Pinnacle of
intelligence or that we're the Pinnacle
God I hope we're not yeah or that we're
the Pinnacle of [__] technology
expertise
you're going to have other
alien races and other alien species that
are millions of years ahead of us that
have the ability to fold space to do
things like slightly warped dimensions
and that's what happens in Star Trek
with warp drive you can't exceed the
speed of light in this time space you
have to warp space around you so
therefore you're traveling forward but
you're not traveling through space
uh that's with the warp drive so you're
gonna have weird [__] like that in the
galaxy
I don't think we're all that interesting
compared to them but there's a chance
that they're that they come here every
now and then to look at some [__]
be like what are these boring ass
[__] up to and they may not
even really care that much about us they
might just be looking well this is a
planet that has life on it let's see
what let's see what the wildlife's doing
let's see what they're up to yeah so
Trey said wouldn't it be funny if like
the aliens have been talking to like
dolphins and whales this whole time yeah
Star Trek said that well and uh I would
I should say too that Mystery Science
Theater did a whole [__] series of
sketches where the Dolphins were like
way more intelligent than humans and
they had already like had they developed
like way higher technology
chances are if aliens were interested in
the earth it's because of the biosphere
all the creatures that are in it they
would come here and look at the humans
and the animals and everything and they
wouldn't see a big difference between us
and the Animals well there's not a big
deal because there's there are millions
of years ahead Millions not thousands
not hundreds of Millions
so
there's not a big difference between an
ape and a hymn or a dog and a human to
them and then they look at our
technology and they don't even really
see that as technology
like we look at an eight using a stick
sticking it in a hole to get some
termites to eat in it that's technology
but we don't really see it as technology
but he made a tool okay well that's
they're so far ahead they look at a
nuclear reactor they laugh at that
their children can do that you know
so
you know if that's what you're dealing
with with these cases
cops happened to see this Superior
species
that for some reason comes here to
observe the Earth
for a small period of time and then they
go back to where they came from or just
go along their way
like you driving down the freeway and
you see a [__] Stork on the side of
the road sitting on a damn [__] fence
or something you don't stop and go talk
to the store you don't care about a
story you say look at hey what's up bird
then keep going
that's what they're doing I mean I might
because I'm like what what is that bird
up to I see a whole mound of ants and I
go take me to your leader no that's not
gonna happen
well I have to say that um if any of you
guys are subscribed to Zay Frank who
does those hilarious like but also
informative like nature videos he put up
he doesn't put up videos that often but
whenever he does they're like a super
treat I'm always like really excited
when he put something up because they're
awesome but he put up one about slime
molds
slime molds are a single celled organism
and yet they can still do mazes they can
still do stuff they don't have a brain
or anything but the [__] that they can
do is
uh pretty impressive honestly I was kind
of impressed at like all the stuff that
slime molds could do for not having a
brain and I was just kind of like well
from an alien standpoint I can see it's
like well maybe humans aren't that
exciting after all because if even slime
molds can do that kind of [__] then a
little jumping spiders in a little
jumping spider like the size of a pencil
eraser those things can see a fly
sitting a fake fly they'll put a fake
fly sitting on a damn leaf and test him
and he can plan out a whole plan of
attack of what leaves he has to jump
across to get above it to jump down on
it
and his brain is smaller than a salt
crystal
yep and they can't figure out how that
how that [__] little tiny brain can
do such Advanced observations of the
[__] environment and to plan things
out see I mean humans aren't as cool as
they thought no
to be honest well we don't really know
how the brain works no it's still
largely mysterious I don't yeah and I
kind of agree with Stuart hammeroff is
that the brain is the brain is important
but a lot of it has to do with the
quantum field that we know of as
consciousness that is around it in a
slightly different dimension and some of
it's in this Dimension and some of it's
in slightly higher Dimensions too a
bunch of quantum particles in
superposition
that are doing a lot of work making you
feel like you are here
that's that's what makes you not AI
you're not AI you are you are a
or no no you are I I was going to say no
you are I you are you you feel like
you're here because you're analog you're
not digital
it's it's wild
and those aliens know all about it they
figured it out
they're just not very impressed with us
we're we're still primitive I'm not
impressed with us either yeah it's going
to take news and I'm not even an alien
it's gonna take millions of years of
evolution and some of it might be
genetic engineering before we actually
get the part what any extraterrestrial
aliens that could come here there are
[__] millions of years ahead of us
biologically if they are biological they
may be technological
you know where they download their souls
into a metaverse that is okay let's go
let's start with the case God damn it
I keep getting sidetracked yeah I wonder
how that happened I don't know I was
gonna say though that like look I am a
human and um I'm really not I mean
humans are just very disappointing to me
it's like I I just wish they would be
better but they're just not they're just
not so I can imagine how much more
disappointed like aliens would be I
don't know I think they just marvel at
us the same way we Marvel at otters and
and [__] ferrets and apes you know
they say it's like it's like that
but you know I don't think they're
disappointed they have lower
expectations they know what they're
looking at when they see us
they don't you know maybe that's what it
is yeah I'm just kind of like well no
they just they're coming here to observe
nature and we're just part of nature
right that's all it is and I think
um but maybe not nowadays but I kind of
feel like some humans have a hard time
with that it's like we're just part of
the natural order we're part of the
[__] floor and fauna and we're really
not any we're not really that much
smarter it's well enough you guys even
got these crazy ass Airy fairy Lefty
people this is Gaia is what you're
talking about it's the biosphere it is
it's a single thing aliens would not
really differentiate much between humans
and animals they would just say yeah
yeah they're all aliens
yeah these are the ones that actually
can do things that they call technology
but you know yeah isn't that cute yeah
but you know wasps can kind of do
technology if you look at the damn nests
they're kind of geometric and orderly
and they're doing things
I'm sure a wasp thinks that their
[__] technological as [__]
yeah well see I always just kind of I
give animals the benefit of the doubt I
kind of feel like they're probably a lot
smarter than we give them credit for
ants and a lot of humans are a lot
dumber than we get you got ants that are
so small you can barely see them all
right and they have whole [__]
organized societies and
you know division of labor and you go
like how the hell does a tiny little
brain like that figure all that out
you know
life finds a way to go to the restaurant
it does yeah
by the way quit picking on lefties
because I'm also a lefty yeah yeah
that's what yeah that's what they all
say that's what they all say
um yeah you're talking about
drive-through liquor stores yeah we had
one at Daytona
where I grew up and we always used to
laugh at that [__] I'm like oh my God
drive through liquor store that's like
not the best idea it's a package store
technically
um yeah you can go in there and buy
liquor that you can you know but
I don't know you're you're not
technically supposed to have like you
know I know we have fans in other
countries you can buy liquor in a
drive-through thing but you're not
allowed to have like an open container
in your car like while you're driving so
and I'm pretty sure that's true of all
states
And Justice For Me said I imagine aliens
view us as the Prometheus Engineers did
it best indifference at worst contempt
yeah that's kind of how I'm feeling as
well I kind of feel like maybe maybe
they're interested in us the same way
that you know Richard Attenborough would
be interested they're like making a
documentary for their version of Netflix
or whatever it is they're just like look
at this weird you know species or
whatever it is and they like kind of
make that and like you know the aliens
are watching that [__] on their Planet
going like look at that [__] that's like
[__] crazy but yeah I kind of feel
like that's how they feel about it I
don't know
I kind of feel like that's why I'm
skeptical of a lot of alien
I don't know so much about like you know
UFO sightings
but people that say that they've had
interactions with aliens I don't really
believe any of that because a lot of
that is very human-centric and I kind of
feel like
humans don't really see themselves the
way an alien species would see humans I
mean humans are from an alien standpoint
would probably not be that interesting I
feel like
we wouldn't really be that many we
wouldn't be that far removed from like a
chimpanzee or a gorilla or something
like that we're really not that
different so I don't really think that
they would be oh we're gonna come here
and like do anal probes and all this
other kinds of because why would they
care I just feel like they wouldn't you
know what I mean
I just you know so all right so let's
finally now that we're an hour and 18
minutes in yeah I know
I mean we kind of talked about you have
to work we're kind of talking about yeah
we're not talking about UFOs yeah sort
of we're talking about aliens we're
talking about aliens
all right
now that I'm nice and liquored up we're
gonna talk about and now I have to like
read the notes but at least I can still
kind of read okay and you know about
this case yeah so you can like back me
up yeah [__] yeah I know about the case
yeah which is good
so the Belgian UFO wave all right so
this is something that took place
between
about the end of November of 1989 to
April 1990. so maybe like what is that
like six months something like that like
that kind of time period
and this happened in uh Belgium like I
said the Forgotten country
except I I said earlier I was like I
thought Jean-Claude Van Damme was there
but somebody said uh no he was Flemish
so I guess not okay so just flat out
that the Flemish were in Belgium wait
yeah was that no that's that's Flanders
and that's Flemish in Belgium nothing
these countries are the size of an
American County you know what I mean and
they ah never mind they have their own
languages and everything
well see that's what yeah well that's
what's cool about Europe yeah it's like
man
in in a way it's like it's crazy how the
United States is like completely
different to that because we have this
massive country with all these other
states but we have the and each state
has kind of their own like unique
culture and stuff but we have kind of
like a larger
culture sort of
yeah but Europe is just kind of like
they have like a you know each state has
its very own descent like they have
their own language and they have their
own culture and it's old right it's
ancient yeah but well that yeah but that
that's the thing like size doesn't
really like uh you know the size of the
culture doesn't really matter all that
much you know what I mean
Victor says Google says Jean-Claude was
born in uh sent Agatha bersham Belgium
okay so I was right about that okay so
I'm not crazy
somebody told me earlier I was like I
was like he's Belgian right and it's
like I thought somebody was like
correcting me I'm like I'm pretty sure
he's Belgian though yeah it's the fake
friends the fake friends
I'm [__] with him we love we love B
Belgium well it's just like sometimes
well they don't like they're they don't
do much which I guess is good because
they don't do much of anything that like
draws like a lot of like Global
attention or anything like that place
man yeah and it's just like
I mean that doesn't mean anything you
know because like you know a lot of
places are small places but they still
have like large impacts but it's like
we're just gonna like keep it on the
down low you know what I mean we're not
gonna do anything like that's gonna
bring the whole world's attention it's
just we'll just be in the background
doing our own thing you know what I mean
so yeah so this was like a I thought it
was a few month period
late 80s early 90s where uh allegedly a
bunch of people saw some kind of
triangle type UFOs which like I said
kind of feels like that was like a very
early 90s thing saying the black
triangles well it still goes on it does
but I kind of feel like there were a lot
around this time period we did do a show
about the UFO over Illinois which is
also another black triangle type thing
and like
um and Trey said earlier there was the
whole uh Hudson Valley thing which I
thought
I thought I was gonna add on to this but
now I'm kind of glad that I didn't some
critics have said or Skeptics have said
you know these black triangle uh these
triangular shape UFO reports so kind of
coincide with uh
1977 Star Wars
remember how they had the big Imperial
cruiser that's a triangle I don't know
yeah I saw some uh [__] that said well
because okay I can get why people say
that because in the 1950s like when UFO
sightings first started you know there
was the whole Roswell thing and
everything
but I kind of feel like when people
reported UFO settings back in the day
um they kind of reported the same stuff
that was in the movies like saucer yeah
after Star Wars came out with the sort
of triangular shaped
Star Destroyer type type of uh craft
then a little bit after that then
everybody suddenly started seeing
triangular shape which does kind of give
me pause that is a little bit suspicious
I'm gonna counter that a little bit
there there were sightings a long time
before that that went back into the 50s
and the 40s that did say triangles
triangle shape uh and then I'm going to
say another thing that might add to it
the triangle
is the most basic of any kind of
geometrical structure okay if it only
has if it's only two points it'll be a
line
you add a third Point it'll be a
triangle
triangles are structurally real
um sound you can you can apply a lot of
pressure onto on them before they crack
or break
so if you were going to have like a
some kind of a extra dimensional it's
some kind of spacecraft that can kind of
go in and out of higher dimensions and
warp space and time as we know it
a triangle shape would be pretty good
especially if you're not confined
especially if you're not confined to
biology
in other words you don't have to have
like a uh a crew compartment in the
middle because I'm kind of convinced
that what these are basically like
something out of them 2001 A Space
odyssey's monoliths they're more like
that I think there's aliens in them but
I think it's just their souls and it's
their souls inside of a metaverse that's
what I think it is it doesn't make sense
that there's
a breathable atmosphere in there to
support biological creatures and all
that [__] is inefficient it's more
efficient to download the [__] soul
into a into a database and they're in a
metaverse where they're in their own
little personal heavens
for the duration of the trip and that
they live in there that they don't have
a planet that does it it's like a
city-state
the ship if you want to call it a ship
that's what I think it is they're like
old people that buy a Winnebago and go
all around yeah
they may be sold that their planet's
long gone
you know so they don't have a home
planet they don't have biology I don't
think
Victor says also french fries were
invented in Belgium yep that's true
so they gave the world something other
than Jean-Claude Van Damme
[Laughter]
french fries probably more culturally
lasting
yeah but [__] the United States gave
she didn't call it gave Jean-Claude Van
Damme yeah we gave him cocaine
so he that that's you know without
America we didn't invent cocaine yeah
yeah that's from America
well it's from the America from the
Americas yeah yeah the cacao plant
okay there would have been those
Jean-Claude Van Damme without cocaine
without cocaine or America is that a
controversial oh yeah no that's not
controversial at all he'll admit he'll
admit it yeah he liked his cocaine
he was a creature of the 80s we got to
get to the [__] case though come on
everybody was on cooking yeah yeah
Victor says Jean-Claude Van Damme made
me gay when I was 12. yeah you were born
gay bro
you saw Jean-Claude and it was confirmed
yeah
man they're trying to suck me off into
these are [__] sucking me off these
gay dudes trying to suck me off of
course they've just said it not me
they're trying to [__] take me down
these other damn directions
Jean-Claude [__] he was the weird he
was he was [__] he was very European
back in the 80s your average American
action star would be this Macho
[__] with the [__] his face
his muscles and [__] on the poster with
a [__] gun and [__] women around
Jean-Claude had come out with some
[__]
promotional shots of him in the nude
caressing a [__] leopard and [__]
like that within his [__] Speedos and
[__] [__] never but obviously there
was an audience for that yeah there was
man something's slightly gay about
Jean-Claude Van Damme but like from the
American audience for that yeah from the
from the American perspective it was
slightly gay I think
Ben says funniest Onion article ever is
why do these homosexuals keep sucking my
[__] exactly
dude I asked myself a [__] same thing
man [__] just wake up and that's why
that's just that's why that [__] is
funny Jenny trying to save me from it
and everything pulling me away and [__]
yeah I don't know man it's [__] I
understand why it's funny because dudes
are like very they will go through all
kind of like Hoops to be like why one
thing is gay why another well the thing
that I'm doing is not gay even though it
clearly is gay
because like I'm 100 heterosexual okay
because they're very I mean they're very
worried about it they're very worried
about this very binary I don't get it
but okay okay it's like a having a badge
man the street your street badge yeah
why are you worried about it I'm not
worried about it it's just it is I kind
of feel like you maybe I'm just saying
it's like she's trying to do no I'm not
worried about I don't care
I don't care
I really don't care I'm just kind of
like hey whatever you do I don't worry
about like classifying people in one
thing or they I'm just like look do what
you do
I like tits and ass it's not my job to
like put a label on whatever you're
doing just do whatever you're doing
I'm not bothered it doesn't have
anything to do with me I'm not involved
even if I am involved
you know what I mean it's it's really
nothing to do with me you you do you
it's fine what are you trying to tell me
nothing I'm not trying to tell you okay
all right
I'll try to tell you
all right so where was I okay so the
whole thing started in November of 1989.
now as we mentioned earlier a lot of the
reports that
um they said happened at the time
actually happened later but we'll get
into that like later on
but the reports that were that came out
later
uh basically said a lot of them yeah we
saw this kind of like flat triangular
shape with lights underneath that's what
a lot of people reported
so November 29th 1989 and this happened
just outside a very small town called
and I'm sure I'm pronouncing this wrong
but
upon yeah yeah I mean I took French for
four years but I'm still like not real
sure about my pronunciation so yeah this
is uh very close to the border between
Belgium and Germany
so you got two guys who are uh of the
the like basically Belgium cops the
gender Marie or whatever they call it
we're gonna call them uh nickel which
was his last name in montege which I
think the other guy's name we're getting
down to the [__] testimony the
testimony testified testified testify no
I believe these cops I saw their
interviews the [__] read their body
language I believe would I believe that
they did well that's what we're going to
talk about right now let's talk about it
so they're out on there doing their
patrol like they do
now one of them says we're kind of
coming up to this Crossroads
and we saw a field
um just you know on the by the side of
the road that was lit up like a football
field yeah you know and because they're
Europeans that means soccer but same
kind of thing yeah a stadium right like
Stadium lights yeah I said it was like
super bright
so it's like we thought that was really
weird so we wanted to figure out uh what
that was obviously because we thought it
was strange
so we pulled over and then we started
like watching this [__] and then they
said that they saw this big
here's the words that they used a huge
triangular platform
and they said underneath it was
headlights I'm not sure if that's like a
translation probably it had like
probably yeah like he just said like
yeah big round lights that shine like
Bright Lights like Bright Lights that's
basically what they were saying which
that that matches up with other
sightings here in the United States
around this time lights that shine beams
down
that's what he's talking about yeah and
he said in the middle of the head the
headlights or the bright lights was this
other orange light that was like kind of
blinking
and he said the whole thing looked like
it was floating so it was like you know
hovering in the air essentially
so the two guys call up the dispatcher
in you know upan uh whose name was uh
Albert kreutz
now this guy says okay so they called me
up and they say oh we're seeing this
weird ass thing in the sky
um and they said that it didn't make a
noise and we thought they were kidding
like basically they made some like jokes
about oh maybe it's Santa Claus or
something like that so they didn't
really take it seriously what okay now
the triangle that they're talking about
if you add all of the triangles stories
together
I think they're talking about the same
kind of craft
they tend to have a red light in the
center and the three corners have
a white light in them
each time it's described it's slightly
different
which may be important about what these
lights are I don't think it's just a
light I think it might have something to
do with the drive or the propulsion or
sensors I don't know sometimes it's
described in the same object
okay as a sphere a glowing warm sphere
in each corner
big around we're talking you know 30 40
feet in diameter
sometimes slightly concave into the
craft where if it's if it's a
if it's dim it seems to be concave and
it's kind of swirling orangish white
light in there
sometimes those lights are also
described as
if the craft is up in the air
shining a beam down
that doesn't quite meet doesn't
illuminate the ground in other words it
would look like if you saw it from a
distance
three white lights shining down like
white spikes that fade and they don't
ever hit the ground
in other descriptions is as if it's
closer to the ground
it shoots out sometimes
white lights that illuminate the ground
sometimes it's close to the ground and
it's just glowing it doesn't illuminate
the ground underneath it
so the light intensity varies
and the color kind of varies between
orange or like a A or like a goldish
dim color to Bright
and emanating light like a headlight so
when this guy's seeing it I think what
he's talking about is like a headlight
in the air trying to shine down on the
ground
is fascinating
fascinating with a red light in the
middle percent tending to be pulsating
it and then that light detaches in a lot
of the stories
Okay so
I'm just saying this because
what he is describing lines up with what
other people have described
over a long period of time and more than
one continent
I just find it [__] really
interesting he's describing some kind of
Technology
what we would call technology I think
it's real
okay go ahead okay
so at this point the dispatcher he
doesn't really believe it because he's
not really seeing what they're seeing
um so he just like writes it down in the
log and he's just like yeah whatevs
so the other two guys are still kind of
like following the lights like they're
in their car you know what I mean so
they're like uh watching it
now one of the guys nickel
um he said yeah we could still see it
this whole time because the lights were
like really really bright
and he said they had this uh he called
it a flickering orange ball like
underneath the flickering structure
pulsating right yeah okay
um and so they were kind of like driving
really slowly along the road like
watching it and he said the way that it
acted seemed like there was something or
like some kind of intelligence in there
like it was trying to like watch what
was going on right like on the road
because it was like very low altitude
right
now so they had told the dispatcher uh
whose name was kreutz about this
now he thought it was funny at first but
then uh cruises happened he saw like
some flashing like outside of the window
of his office which was also in uh UPenn
so he looks out the window and he sees
also something like really really bright
and then he's watching whatever this is
out the window and he said that he saw
something that and this is a quote
looked like a laser beam shoot out of
the light and then come back to the
light so this is what you were talking
about earlier yeah weird
and so he's watching that and also like
the two guys in the car are watching
that
and then it was like heading toward the
forest which is kind of like outside the
town or whatever how it's Illustrated in
the shows you see the triangle at a
distance above the tree line
and red lines coming out of the corner
slowly descending down to the Earth and
then they would retract or somebody's
with that's that's some weird [__] light
travels at the speed of light okay well
that's why they call it the speed of
light yeah right which it doesn't go
slowly so what their reporting isn't
light
it's something else
maybe a force field of some sort
but it does glow weird and like you said
what are they doing they're doing
something they're measuring something
squirrels what they're picking yeah I
don't know what it is
[Laughter]
like you mentioned it's not technician
it's not a technology we have yet
but fascinating man I'm a black spot I
mean me and Mirror Image Spock me and my
mirror Spock with our beards we're going
that shit's fascinating fascinating
fascinating yeah
something millions of years ahead or
thousands Maybe
yeah yeah they said one of them said
this was nickel I think he says on each
side of the object which is like a big
triangle
uh he described a laser beam and a ball
that was leaving the object and coming
back as if the ball was trying to
measure something yeah so they were like
following it in their car you know what
I mean that's what they said yeah
so at this point like the guy that they
call like the dispatcher that they
called he had called a bunch of uh
airports like in the area seeing you
know checking if they had seen anything
unusual
now the four airports in the area that
he had phoned said that they had not
seen any unusual activity
so apparently the two guys who initially
saw the thing watched it for 30 minutes
and then they said it just kind of
hovered there for a little while
and then all of a sudden like another
triangular craft kind of comes out of
nowhere
um they said the one that they had been
following with their car was still there
but then like another one came out
and they said there was a second one and
it was kind of like going up in the sky
and then it sort of like tilted a little
bit and they said it looked pretty much
the same as the first one it was like
triangular shaped and it had kind of
like
um you know these bright headlights on
the you know on the corners and then
like one in the middle that was like
kind of reddish orange or whatever they
said exactly like the first one
and then one of them said we could see a
little bit of a dome on the top that had
two or three small Windows on it and
that there was a light inside so I guess
they're kind of like thinking it looks
like like a craft like a craft
essentially and like maybe there's like
little people in there flying it
although I've seen craft like
Jets coming in for a landing at pretty
close distances we've got to fly right
over McDonald's where we were remember
in Sanford yeah we're in the [__] in
in the drive-through and they've come
pretty and you you can't really see you
can't really see windows in it but you
can see lights I I really question
whether or not they're windows that
they're seeing I don't think they're
window that's just how they interpret it
it was just some kind of light on the
surface yeah because I feel like if
something was that far away it's like
could you really tell if it was the
windows or not you can't see the windows
on the side of jets
maybe that's just how they were a person
that's how they were perceived not
really sure but they yeah they basically
said they had a they saw them with like
Windows on it and that there was a light
inside like I said so it looked like a
little like a like a traditional
spacecraft like there'd be little people
in there or whatever little aliens or
whatever
so they said they they kind of clocked
that and then they said that this object
like flew away
now
um yeah so they kind of saw these crafts
like the first the second one like flew
away and then the first one they said it
kind of went toward
um this other Village which is called uh
La Calamine or something like that like
when I saw it on the thing I was like
Kalama like calamine lotion like the
stuff that you put on chickenpox or
whatever so I guess it was kind of that
now apparently
um a couple of cops in
calamine lotion Village that's what I'm
going to call it
um they also reported that they saw this
weird thing in the sky
they thought it was like
they didn't really know what to make of
it at first apparently they thought it
was like kind of a joke or something but
then they like they'd heard the reports
over the radio and they're like what
okay what the [__] ever but then like
they saw something coming toward them
and it was like okay well maybe it's not
uh funny anymore okay
so they said now their first impression
was that they thought it was an airplane
but not one of their airplanes so they
said they thought it was an American
airplane which I'm not really sure what
that implies but
that I don't know that that to me kind
of like
that seemed a little bit significant
that at first they thought it was an
airplane
but they didn't really know what it was
that they were looking at so they said
that it was like right above them
and they said there was another object
that then left the main object there was
like a they described like a red light
that was uh pulsating and would come
down vertically from the main object
and then kind of like would move around
like on its own as if something was
coming down and like searching or
measuring or something like that that
was something that a bunch of them said
now apparently then
uh this particular craft or whatever it
was
apparently turned into a single light
beam
and then kind of just went and like
disappeared yeah
how they showed that
on Unsolved Mysteries is that you see
the triangle
and it's got a solid kind of gray border
around the edges of it
and in the middle it's kind of like a
black center with a bunch of gray pipes
the light in each corner and if I could
rub it in the middle and it kind of
folds in on itself like it's like it got
sucked away into a slightly higher
Dimension and then just shot off in a
beam of light
which man that's that's a good
description of some technology we don't
have
you need that though yeah that's what we
need yeah
I want to go into another dimension just
whenever I feel like it
so apparently all of these uh sightings
took place within about an hour of each
other and within like a 20 mile radius
now on Unsolved Mysteries they actually
said uh that 11 other uh law enforcement
officers and a bunch of and a hundred
something private citizens came forward
with similar reports this is not
entirely true like I said
um those reports came later like about a
week after this initial thing so
not entirely the case
now uh so yeah over the next couple of
months uh a lot of other reports were
cited like I said
once it hit the media
um a lot of people came forward and
claimed that they had seen the same [__]
that these you know uh the gender Marie
had seen
so I don't know I kind of feel like we
can take a lot of those with a grain of
salt because they were kind of like oh
yeah I did I totally saw some [__] too
because there's a thing too where
and I think like Philip class who's like
a big uh UFO skeptic and he's like
written a bunch of stuff about this he's
like what happens once a UFO report
becomes very popular is that
in retrospect like a lot of people are
gonna be like oh my God I saw this the
weird thing in the sky that they didn't
think about at the time but then like a
day or two later like somebody's like oh
my God I saw this weird [__] like a
craft or whatever and they're like oh my
God I saw that [__] too and then they
report that as a sighting when that's
not necessarily what they might have
seen you know what I mean because they
didn't like
perceive it as like a UFO at the time
but like in retrospect they kind of like
went back it's like oh well other people
saw UFO so I guess I saw one too so it
might have been a situation like that
so it's not so much that I'm discounting
that these cops like saw what they saw
I'm just saying that all the subsequent
uh eyewitness reports of like yeah we
all saw it too I don't know how much
Credence you can give to that because a
lot of those came like a week after
after it already hit the media after it
had already become like a thing you know
I give more credibility to the cops
because they would have been awake and
up and observe it at the times that
we're talking about
the general public think about it you're
in your house at night are you looking
out the window
not you [__] no a silent [__] craft
could fly over the top of your your
house and you'd never know it Tom was
saying that last night he's like yeah
it's like what if everybody's like
asleep at like four in the morning yeah
and like the alien just like farting
around up there in the sky for [__]
hours and like everyone's I mean most
people are probably like sleeping other
than people like work at night the
original Night Stalker would walk around
with a gun in between houses [__]
sometimes in the day well no one would
see you and they didn't see him you know
sometimes at night and he'd crawl into
people's windows and you just no you're
not as aware of things as you think
though think about this I mean when we
were living in Sanford we were like uh
in the flight path of a lot of jets
going to the
to the uh to the airport
those things made noise
and we still didn't [__] notice them
you know [__] makes a lot of [__]
noise well after a while after this guy
used to because the airport was only
what right yeah five six seven miles
away something like that so you just you
got used to them flying over the house
big silent [__] triangle could go
over your house and loiter around for a
few minutes and then leave and you'd
never know it man if you're watching
television well if that [__] happened at
like two in the morning I'd probably be
sleeping I wouldn't notice yeah you'd
have or if you were awake you were
watching television you had the lights
off in the [__] window shades closed
you'd never know
maybe aliens know that yeah
I don't even care no probably not I mean
they probably don't even think they care
no yeah
so uh these up a little bit this is the
end of the orange juice I'm gonna put
some lemonade in there too okay that's
fine
so in April of
1990 which was kind of like let's talk
about this a little bit because there
was kind of like a March kind of thing
and I want to get into like the whole
radar uh situation
but this Photograph
um kind of went Global like when the
early 90s equivalent of viral right
and like I said it's very interesting
because
on the Unsolved Mystery Show on the
interview that I saw with Nick Pope that
I'm pretty sure they probably should
have mentioned this
but they showed the photograph which
looks kind of cool like okay so the
photograph is it's basically like a
close-up
of
a triangular shaped craft but there's no
like I said there's no context to it
like you can't really tell like how big
it is or anything like that and you have
to up the brightness and the contrast to
even see that it's a triangle shape
because mostly it just kind of looks
like three lights like in sort of like
triangular formation
so they did that and it's like for a
long time this was a very you're all
right yeah most fall on that I know I
saw that oh my goodness sat down the
[__] chair wasn't there all the way
yeah well
Tom does it he's not aware of where his
butt is
because where were the ass was I didn't
know where the chair was
I mean that amounts to the same thing no
but yeah so I'm just saying that
this photo for a long time and even now
if you Google
uh you know Belgian UFO wave or whatever
it is this is the first photo that will
come up and I hate to like burst
everybody's bubble but this photo is a
fake
um which is crazy because you'd think
that if all these people allegedly saw
this [__]
um at least one person would have gotten
a good photo of it I'm gonna disagree
in the 90s [__] cameras [__] suck
I know that man but come on they're
saying
that that like what 13 400 people
saw this there's that many reports and
nobody took a picture I remember what it
was like back then
cameras were you and you never had a
camera ready
they sucked anyway if you took a picture
of something like this in the distance
it would just be a white light in the
sky okay but like why doesn't it happen
nowadays then when everyone's got
camera well it's more likely now for
something like that to happen then why
don't we see it I don't know maybe they
know
maybe they know maybe aliens know they
said well we can't go down there anymore
they got they got cell phones I kind of
feel like it's probably more likely that
um that it's [__] no I don't think
so
I'm just wondering I'm just wondering
well they got the Phoenix Lights On
video but it's not the it's not the uh
it's not the video with the flares it's
the other one and it in those days it
had been more likely actually to get it
on VHS
because there were people that had VHS
cameras laying around and it was
sometimes easier to get that in because
it was bigger it was easier to get that
into operation than it was those little
[__] maybe those little cheap
instamatic plastic cameras yeah that you
didn't take seriously anyway and you had
to [__] develop them
I mean it was that that cost a lot of
money the VHS camera
was better because you could just
re-record over
images you know
so in the 90s I think it'd be more
likely to get something on video
than it would be to get something on the
film
I had all kinds of cameras and never had
one around me
they were always like in a closet
or in a drawer
and I always forget about it never take
it with me and I just never [__] had
any film in it you know and buying film
and getting the film it's just no but
that's it for a while I mean we did too
yeah I'm just saying is that
up until
um you know smartphones with cameras
became ubiquitous
I'm willing to give some people some
leeway yeah I couldn't get a picture of
it because I I get it like I was around
back then you couldn't really get a
picture of [__] like I didn't have a
camera handy or nothing like that
nowadays there's no excuse so where is
the footage they stopped somebody should
get that
either they stop coming or it was always
[__] to start with
uh there's another way you can look at
it they're very intelligent they're
millions of years ahead they can listen
to [__] our internet they can listen
to [__] television or whatever they
know what the level of Technology we
have we might be banned now
you never know like okay you can't go
there you're sick they're sick of our
[__] and what you see now is things like
the Tic Tac the UFO the Tic Tac UFOs
you know which jet fight jet Pilots can
see those
you know but they just maybe they're not
they're not allowed to do the big
parades like they used to I mean I'm
just wondering I mean and I kind of feel
the same about any kind of like
Paranormal anything whether it's like
UFOs or ghosts or anything like that
it's like look everybody has an HD
camera in their pocket not everybody but
like essentially everybody has an HD
camera in their pocket nowadays another
thing that could happen why are you guys
not taking pictures maybe they are
that's another thing well and the thing
about it though is that even if you did
take pictures of the [__] people would
say it was fake well because you can
fake it because you can fake it um AI is
so good yeah like dude I can go to a
free app right now
and just put in a sentence yeah and they
will make a photo yeah of whatever I
typed I've seen a lot I've seen a lot of
videos the [__] UFOs recently
like [__] UFO flying over the damn
palm trees and everything and I go I can
look at it and go yeah that looks real
man that's impressive but I know that
that's fake because it's too good to be
true yeah and then later on you'll see
an analysis of that video and they're
going like yeah look when it goes behind
that palm tree the resolution cuts down
they weren't able to really get that to
work behind it but it was like Hollywood
level
yeah Foolery but that's well I mean I
told you it's like you know I've been a
graphic designer for a long time it's
like and the AI today is amazing yeah so
even if you saw a photo or video
nowadays you couldn't trust it right
because it's very very easy they're fake
and pretty much anybody like I could
fake it you know and all those fakes
they may be a few new few real ones
that's what I'm saying but it's like
there's no way of knowing and then like
because it's so easy to face yeah and
then you look and then you go like well
and then like we had somewhere to know
which of the real ones were you look at
the real ones and it's just [__]
three lights in this guy
that's what I'm saying yeah and there's
no there's no [__] so there's no
depth there's no I mean I'm not [__]
on people that actually believe in it
like maybe they did film some [__] that
really happened I'm just saying that
it's one it's so easy to fake nowadays
that it's like
I don't really see right even if
somebody came out and said hey look at
what look what I recorded it's like you
don't really know like I could fake that
[__] like in an afternoon come on the
stuff that the Navy says is real with
the [__] UF the Tic Tac UFO stuff
I'll look at it and go yeah that's a
real image
but that's not a [__] UFO okay I mean
you don't identify it but that's not an
alien craft like the one where they're
locking onto that little thing going on
that's what I'm saying Parallax yeah
well and I kind of feel like too A lot
of the UFO sightings
um you know I'm not saying there's
nothing there I'm just saying that it's
probably not
extraterrestrial it's either like an
experimental craft or it's something
that you're not identifying because I
see weird [__] all the time you know
people see weird [__] in the sky all the
time you don't know what that is that
isn't necessarily because that's a huge
leap saying that's from another planet
or another galaxy or another dimension
or whatever that's like a whole other
um you know hurdle that you have to go
over the one with a little dot the
racing above the waves and those guys
are trying to lock onto it it's an
illusion it's Parallax all right it's
not it's not low moving quickly over the
waves
it's halfway in between the craft and
the waves at about [__] fifteen
thousand feet all right they're passing
it and they're trying to [__] lock
onto it and in the background it looks
like the waves are moving by real fast
but it's not moving at all I think it's
just a balloon or a [__] paper bag
that's been blown up by the wind
and they're trying to lock onto a paper
bag and they're moving fast
all right the paper bag isn't so behind
it The Parallax makes it look like
[__] waves are moving but in the
background real fast like it's just
right above the surface it isn't it's an
optical illusion called parallax
like like I said too like human
perception is not perfect yeah like if
you see something and you're not
entirely sure what you're looking at you
can like interpret it in lots of
different ways that maybe you're not
correct yeah the other one is you know
they're turning left and the thing turds
right I've noticed that that looks like
some kind of a camera problem it's got a
camera flare
and a camera on a ball trying to [__]
zoom in on an object and they're turning
one way because he turns one way and
then the object turns equally the
opposite direction which that's very
unlikely that's something mechanical
having to do with
how that camera's mounted it's mounted
on a ball with a pintle
so it's trying to lock onto something
but he moved the aircraft one way and it
made it appear as if the image turned
the opposite way
but it's it's some kind of camera era
there may have been something out there
but it turning
has to do with that camera on a ball on
a mount
that's what that was
so
you're they're seeing an anomaly but
it's not extraterrestrial in those two
cases and I mean I kind of feel like you
should always err on the side of this is
an Earthly phenomenon right
um that we don't understand yet like
you're jumping to extraterrestrial
that's like a massive yeah that's a
whole other can of worms that you have
to open the thing is though is that
whenever they talk about the Tic Tac UFO
they show those two images and those are
not really directly related to to the
Tic Tac UFO thing
that pilot described a very different
thing that he saw something down on the
surface of the water moving in a in like
a crisscross pattern and then below it
near the water with some foam and then
it came up to medium and they circled
around each other and then it took off
and they won't show pictures of that
all right there's the he said he had he
said that he gave camera footage over of
it
but they took it you know the they have
it but they didn't release it
all right right the thing of the the
thing of the uh
the other so-called famous Tic Tac one
the one I was saying that the craft
turns one way and then the image turns
the other way that was the second group
that came out there to look at it
they released that footage
which tells me that that footage doesn't
show anything if it showed something
they wouldn't have released it
yeah pretty much yeah they wouldn't
release it
so like I said the famous photo is
um the everybody pretty much
acknowledges that that's a hoax right
that was made of like uh you know
styrofoam essentially which we'll get
into a little bit later
1990 like between 1990 and 1992 I feel
like
um the Belgian authorities got
thousands of phone calls like talking
about like sightings and stuff but like
I said at that point
it was very very up in the you know in
the media like it was a very popular
thing to talk about so it could have
been like a bunch of cranks you know
what I mean
so they didn't really know like what was
going on now you have this whole
organization which consists of just
random citizens you got some scientists
in there stuff like that it's called
sobeps now this is a privately funded
organization
now I will say that sobeps I don't know
if this is their stated agenda or not
but they are very like I don't know if I
want to say UFO positive but they are
very
um
you know uh kind of involved in the idea
that maybe these are extraterrestrials
so a lot of these stories that came out
later on about this particular incident
or a series of incidents came from them
so I'm not entirely sure how objective
they are about the stuff because like I
said they're very
committed to the idea that these are
extraterrestrial
now they did apparently like work with
the Belgian military and the cops and
everything like that
now so there were a couple sightings
like I said the the cops were the main
sightings there were a couple of other
ones
um you know just of random citizens
although I kind of feel like
I read this big long paper about it and
it seemed like a lot of the uh sightings
that happened prior to that were
probably helicopters
um just the way that they described them
but you know what I mean so they're
talking about that
and then in March of 1990 you had your
other uh your big
next wave of Belgian UFO sightings and
this is kind of like where we're talking
about like the radar type stuff
so the first thing that happened in
March of 1990 you have this uh other
gender Marie cop type person it was
Captain Jacques pencil was his name
so he gets called to this house outside
of uh Brussels in Belgium and a bunch of
people at a dinner party apparently like
said they saw all these weird lights in
the sky so they called in and reported
now what they reported at first was that
they saw these lights
and that
it's like there were kind of like stars
but they were like a lot bigger and a
lot brighter and like different colors
than stars were like they said they were
like reddish or yellow
um and some of them were green and they
were like much bigger so they looked
like very very strange and they were the
way they were moving was obviously not
like stars so they called them like
reported it
now apparently um several miles away at
a NATO tracking station
uh on the on radar
an unknown object uh had come up on the
radar at the pretty much the same
location that the dinner guests had
reported seeing these weird lights
so on uh we watched like the Unsolved
Mysteries you know about this and they
talked about uh they kind of showed like
a reenactment of it and they're like
yeah it looked like this little dot with
like a little tail on it is basically
what it looked like and I've seen like
the real uh radar footage of it too
which is kind of the same thing as what
it looked like
so they called up apparently like a
bunch of other military radar sites like
in the area
and they're like yeah we've got the same
Echo going on in the same place so it's
like we don't really know what that is
um so this like we don't know if this is
like a friendly
craft of some kind or like an enemy or
something like that it's like we don't
know if it's an aircraft we don't know
what the [__] it is
so at this point
um because they had had confirmation
that there was something unusual from
four different radar stations uh the
Belgian Air Force uh got alerted
so they're like well something weird is
up there so just go check it out so they
sent two f-16s from the Belgian Air
Force uh out they scrambled them and
they sent them up uh to see what was
going on
now according to the story the pilots
um they locked onto the object with
their onboard radar and started like
chasing whatever it was that it was that
it was
but they said after a couple of seconds
that the object started like just flying
out of range like super super fast every
time they got a lock on it it would take
off right that's what they said that's
what they well I mean like I said that's
what they said at least on this show
like it was being evasive right
um they said yeah it was like not like a
conventional aircraft it was moving like
a lot quicker
so they said over the next hour uh the
pilots were like yeah it kind of seems
like it's trying to like evade us
um and it's moving like way faster than
um an actual aircraft would be yeah High
mock and it wasn't even a sonic boom
behind it
yeah they said um they're like we've
never seen an aircraft like accelerate
this quickly
so basically when they apparently uh
analyzed the um you know the the radar
footage like afterward they were like
apparently when the pilots first select
locked onto the um to the thing
uh the object whatever it was was at
about seven thousand feet
but within a few seconds it went to ten
thousand feet and then dropped down to
like 500 feet like within just a couple
of seconds which would have killed
somebody through negative G and yeah
they said if that was a person like if
that was a human pilot that would have
killed them because it was going like
way faster than a human could withstand
so there was that
um also uh as you mentioned earlier they
said nobody in the area reported any
Sonic Boom even though the thing was
going at least one and a half times the
speed of tap of sound
um now one thing that Unsolved Mysteries
mentioned that I thought was kind of
interesting was that even though there
had been supposedly thousands of
sightings in Belgium as a whole
um there really hadn't been any other
sightings in letting any surrounding
countries like France or Germany or any
or the Netherlands or anything like that
um which they said well that's kind of
like Skeptics they'll be like well
that's why because you guys were just
seeing [__] and like we didn't see
anything over here and we're just like
right by you you know what I mean so
there was that
but
um one thing that I don't know I I
thought this was kind of like I gotta
say look man the shot that might read
the [__] from the from the
the from what I saw the interviews
that one guy was like yeah people you
know I don't care if you don't believe
me I I saw it you know what I mean I
felt privileged to see it it was
beautiful but they saw it so I I kind of
feel the dude I'm like you know what I
mean he he said that he saw it and many
other guys I mean I get it and I believe
that they did they saw something and and
I believe that their description of it
was accurate I don't know what that is
like I said jumping to extraterrestrial
is that's always like a
because that could be lots of Earthly
things maybe but not if I would you know
what I'm saying that could be a lot
there was the only thing maybe I'll talk
about it later there's only a couple
purported crafts that exist
that that could be
and one of them a tr3
I think is a fictional craft that was
made up to fit this case oh yeah I was
there I was listening to something yeah
there's that became like an urban legend
yeah that's there was no tr3 but there
were stealth zeppelins
that did exist and maybe they still do
that are
triangular
that are silent
that may have been equipped with some
kind of psychological camouflage another
bunch of LED lights that could act as a
screen which they probably had that
technology in the 90s that would have
been skunk work type [__]
so when you see this [__] Zeppelin
and it's putting on this impressive
light display you reported it as a
[__] UFO sighting and nobody believes
you that's a form of camouflage
you you're making this object appear so
bizarre nobody believes you whether you
see it or not doesn't matter
because you're not believed that's a
good psychological warfare [__]
camouflage see that's always the first
thing I go to because to me that seems a
lot more believable the ones here that
the cops saw on the [__] um
uh uh on on the Illinois case
they showed that cop the drawing from
Popular Mechanics when they talked about
that for that that stealth Zeppelin it
went black after that they didn't talk
about it after that and he goes yeah it
could have been that
he said it's made a buzzing sound when
it when it hovered and it took off but
it had a very high rate of acceleration
at a low altitude
so it wouldn't be normal propulsion like
propellers or jets
would have been something maybe
electromagnetic I don't know
electrostatic Drive
something that could move air over the
surface electrically
to make an airflow
but if you're talking that then you're
talking about nuclear power probably
which might mean why they that might
explain why we don't know about it
because that's an in violation of a
bunch of treaties
to have a nuclear-powered aircraft we
had that for a little while with a
bomber converted to it in the 50s
but I still think it's unlikely I don't
think there's a need for any of that in
the inventory
it would have been something custom made
and I don't know why they'd need it
because satellites could do a job like
that
I think I'm probably extraterrestrial
but just you know I don't know like I
said to me it seems a lot more likely
that
even if I don't want to go to the thing
where it's like oh it's Mass delusion
because at some point it's like yeah
that's that's reaching but
um I'm not like discounting that people
did see something but I kind of feel
like it's a lot more likely to think
that this was just like an experimental
uh you know craft of some kind that
nobody wanted to know about
that people ended up seeing rather than
it being extraterrestrial because that's
a whole other
level above I'm not saying it's it's not
that I'm just saying I'm going with the
more likely scenario
so I'm not saying that they didn't see
anything I'm just saying that it might
have not been extraterrestrial see
there's theoretically some weird ways
that you could take a solid body
Zeppelin
and if you had enough power you could
you could emit microwaves along the
Leading Edge which would heat up and
expand the air in front of it
which admit and then you could use some
kind of electromagnetic electrostatic
propulsion to move air molecules over
the surface of it and it would slip into
a low pressure Zone as it went
but I don't think you could give I don't
think it'll move very fast I think it
would move slowly but you know
I don't know best way is to just punch
your way through the air using a jet
engine or a rocket real high but those
make a lot of noise
but just the speeds
that the cops reported here in America
when the thing's accelerated you're
talking about at least
600 miles an hour you know which is damn
near Mach 1.
now sometimes it went slowly but then it
would just take up and be gone so man I
just don't think you could do that with
some kind of an exotic propulsion like
electrostatic drive and microwave
emission to BR to expand air molecules
on the Leading Edge and that sounds
[__] high-tech as [__]
but usually when you're talking about
stuff like that you see the actual
application it's weak as [__] usually
you know the dumb old-fashioned ways
tend to be the best
just [__] burn a bunch of [__] and
[__] explode it inside a [__]
rocket nozzle you'll take off fast you
know you know
but all that [__] high-tech electric
[__] usually doesn't work out
Trey says man I just want to say I am
loving this episode
like I said you know
but yeah so
um here's the thing
so 1992 which was a couple years after
kind of like the big because like I said
this was a wave it started like in late
1989 it went until like the spring of
1990 but I kind of feel like the end of
March 1990 was kind of when the big that
was when the ray all the radar stuff
happened
um but the thing about it is that
[Music]
um
the one uh several of the people that
criticized even in Belgium and like
worldwide that looked into this
afterward they said the problem with the
whole thing was that sobeps which was
you know this uh independent group that
supposedly uh investigated all this
stuff they had a pretty vested interest
in this being extraterrestrial and
because of like some books and papers
and stuff like that that they put out it
almost seemed like their narrative about
what happened became the overarching
narrative you know what I'm saying so a
couple
um of people called them out on that
later it's like look all the information
is coming from you guys and it's like we
don't and it's not really accurate uh
they were controlling the narrative at
that point and the people that were
criticizing them were not really getting
any play they weren't really getting the
same level of uh media scrutiny or media
um you know attention that sub episode
was getting because they were just kind
of like and so bad so like I said
they're not a government agency they're
not anything like that they're just like
other contractors they're just private
contractors yeah it's a couple
scientists in there but mostly like
people that are like UFO Believers
um so you have to kind of like take a
lot of their stuff with the grind
assault is what I'm saying
um and some uh some researchers
afterwards said that they were kind of
maybe spreading misinformation because
you know the story was kind of coming
from them a lot of the uh things that
you read online about this particular
case nowadays like online came from
books and stuff like written by their
members or like put out by them
so a lot of the other stuff is not I
must say in the defense of the case
though that the Belgian Air Force
General that
gave the Press briefings and released
the um the radar
data
from that one case he believed it I've
seen other I I've seen other
um interviews with him outside of uh
of
Unsolved Mysteries
and some people said well that
particular radar had problems and he's
like yeah but no I know this radar
system those readings were correct there
was an object there that didn't was in
that location and didn't move that fast
he said I just don't know what it is
you know so that particular Belgian
General did believe the radar data from
the f-16s
yeah he believed it although uh yeah
I'll get into I'll get in other people
say no there were problems with that
radar
but the thing is is guys that actually
know those radar systems know those
problems
and know how to recognize them usually
there was equipment I was issued I knew
it had problems but we knew when it was
when it was [__] up and when it
wasn't but we'll see what Jenny dug up
uh I will say too and this is actually
online if you want to read it um it's a
paper it's about 25 pages long uh it's a
PDF
and it's called the Belgian UFO wave of
1989 1992 and neglected hypothesis and
it's by a guy named uh Renault leclay
and Company
um his whole thing is that he thinks
that a lot of the sightings were
probably helicopters and he gives like a
lot of photographic evidence like
showing what the witnesses described and
like what apparent like um you know kind
of helicopters like look like and it's
pretty compelling like I said if you
want to read it it's free you can read
it online if you want to I read it like
earlier today
and it does seem like to explain some of
the stuff
um and he points out too that even
though a lot of later
uh you know accounts of the thing said
that oh everybody said it was silent but
they select the original accounts where
most people said it made like a low
noise like a motor so
um he's saying that a lot of them might
have been helicopters
but in the defense of that even the guys
in uh even the cops in um
Illinois said no it made a kind of a
humming sound kind of like a Transformer
you know that like an electric sound
like somebody you know what I mean like
like a like like high voltage lines yeah
like so yeah they didn't from the
beginning they didn't say it was silent
they did say it made a noise but I kind
of feel like it evolves later to say
it's like silent yeah
evidently they'd make like a humming
sound like an electrical sound right
I have to say too that the original
story of like the two
um uh gendarms that were the original
guys that uh saw it
um they're actually their first account
was first published in a tabloid in
Germany
and a lot of these subsequent stories
kind of came from that so
um the guy that interviewed them was
also like a big uh advocate of like a
UFO and like alien stuff so he was kind
of like trying to make it seem like it
was real like I'm not saying it's not
real I'm just saying you have to take
all this kind of stuff into uh you know
consideration is what I'm saying
because everybody and like uh basically
the guy that was into
uh SOB apps like one of the main
scientific guys was a physics Professor
uh whose name was uh August Meson and he
was like a real big believer in that
extraterrestrials were visiting the
planet so he was like really into
kind of like maybe bolstering that
assertion is what I'm saying I'm not
saying it's not true I'm just saying
that you have to like take that into
consideration
and he's kind of like the main guy
that's brought into about that kind of
stuff so like I said there's a book that
came out called the Belgian UFO wave uh
sobeps actually released that book and
Misan who I talked about before he was
kind of the lead author of it and he's
kind of like the the main source for
subsequent stories about it and he very
very clearly believes that this was
extraterrestrial that this was like a
alien spacecraft
now
um so interestingly uh so like I said
Skeptics have come forward and said well
either this whole thing was like a mass
delusion in the sense of you know
somebody saw something weird in the sky
and then they reported in the media and
then suddenly everybody else said oh
yeah I saw some weird [__] too and then
like reporting that it seemed like that
a lot more people report it than
actually had so that might have been the
case also
you know like you read a story about
something and then
you know the media says hey we need more
people that saw this kind of stuff it's
like oh yeah people are going to jump up
right so that's where they get because
like I said they you know they make a
lot if you go to like a UFO site or
something like that so oh my God 143
reports of this it's like that's those
weren't from the time though those came
like afterward it kind of reminds me of
uh
the Phoenix Lights case
five symington
the [__] governor in the end came out
says oh yeah I saw that thing too
all right now other people that did see
it or claim that they see it
then went on famous Witnesses then went
on to say no Simonton lied he couldn't
have seen it at that place at that time
it wasn't there
it was over here that type of [__]
accusing five simonsen of the peer
pressure of wanting to say oh yeah I saw
it too I saw it too right right which
that may be that may have happened see
that's what I was saying before you
can't ever believe
one person's account of anything well I
don't know if that's necessarily true
but I'm just some you know depending on
the situation but it's like a lot of
times you need some other corroborating
evidence because people could make up
stories for all kinds of different
reasons and simonton's defense though
he said he went out to go see it he did
see it in a certain place in time and
you you can you can find his account of
it
he goes I don't know what it was but it
wasn't for this world and he did he was
I could I could sense from him it
spooked him
it was just a large silent craft with a
bunch of lights on it shaped like a
carpenter Square
now some people said well he couldn't
have seen it at that place at that time
because it was over here at that place
at the time other people said that well
there's more than one of them and then
who are you to say that this thing can't
move fast yeah [__] was
evidently moved real fast if it got here
from another [__] world you know
so who knows who knows I wish I could
have seen it I remember when when the
Phoenix Lights went down and it was
talked about on Art Bell
and then it went mainstream after that
it was even on the news people said that
they that it maybe happened
it was quite a sensation at that time I
was
I didn't know what to think but I
definitely wanted to see it so I was
like man I wish I was there to have seen
that I want to see that for myself
I think something happened pretty sure
I mean I don't know like my my default
stance is always like that's [__]
until you prove to me otherwise yeah I
understand I understand you know what I
mean I'm just I've always been that way
it's less likely than other [__] that I
know that I've that's what I'm saying
well the thing about it is like I kind
of come at things uh from like a
statistical standpoint How likely is it
that this really happened
um and honestly most of the time it's
more likely that people are mistaken or
they're making stuff up or something
like that because that happens a lot
that's a lot more likely than aliens
that's for sure I don't think so I think
aliens are [__] a definite the aliens
do exist
right but the fact of aliens existence
of aliens coming to Earth are two
completely different I don't dispute the
fact that there's other life forms out
in the universe I'm I would probably
guarantee it 100 yeah that that does not
that would not surprise me but they're
not they're coming here whether they're
visiting the Earth that's a whole other
different question I'm gonna give it 50
50. I'm sorry I'm gonna give it 55. I
mean I don't know I don't know I don't
know if I'd give it though and you know
maybe they do but why would they
it's also just kind of a thing where you
know
they're in the area so they check it out
chances are
there's more than one of them and they
know about this place they've known
about it for [__] millions of years
they know about Earth they've probably
known about Earth
even before humans were on it before we
evolved you know
so they're probably very ancient I don't
think they're biological either I think
they're just uh technological they're
like AI
but they got Souls you know basically
there's an advanced form of life I'm
sure they know about us have known for a
long time they're probably Immortal too
because once you reach that [__]
level of technological development why
would you die
you know what I mean you'd figure out a
way to keep that from happening
so this [__] probably [__] can
live for trillions of years
Camp guys said they they say that the
planet Venus is often mistaken for a UFO
it's out at Dusk and Dawn a lot yeah um
it doesn't move
that's the thing I'm not really but it
is like very very important yeah but I
mean you know I'm kind of like I you
know I took astronomy in school so it's
like I kind of know where Venus is at at
any particular time so you know what I
mean it's I can see how somebody that
didn't know what it was would maybe
mistake it because it is like very
bright but you know what I mean
so uh so yeah so this Photograph as we
mentioned earlier yeah um which was fake
it was actually taken by uh a then 18
year old guy named Patrick uh Mary shawl
yeah he trolling his ass off I give I
give I give props to the kids which yeah
I mean at this point like he confessed
in 2011 that he had done it and he like
invited the media over and he showed him
how he did it and like took the picture
and everything it was like oh yeah okay
fair enough
um basically and it's hilarious like how
simple it is to fool people but he's
like basically we just cut a triangle
out of Styrofoam was yeah it had
um edges on it it looked like yeah uh
they painted it black they put like
flashlights in each of the angles like
each of the corners and just hung it
from a string and took a picture of it
with no background or anything like that
and they're like look it's a [__]
alien group because like I said there
was a lot of media at that time it
looked like the damn avrakar flying
Spade right which is kind of like a
Delta win flat edges on the edge of it
and you put two light three lights in it
whichever four I mean fair play he
fooled people for a long time he took it
took a picture of it under the right
conditions when it was moving so it
would kind of drag some of the light
around and if you magnified the [__]
resolution you could actually see the
outer edge of the ship he knew what he
was doing and it is done he knew how to
he but he was hoaxing yeah he's trolling
like I said he was an 18 year old kid at
the time yeah and it was very much in
the media so he was like wouldn't it be
funny if I troll him
and it works I got a picture of the
mothership it worked yeah
that's still like the number one photo
that comes up
all the time just like they show the
[__] flares from the [__] Phoenix
Lights case that is obviously I haven't
well I used that photo for our um for
our thumbnail but that's because I knew
it was fake and I was just kind of like
well this is the main photo that's
associated with it even though everybody
knows it's fake nowadays but you know
it's still kind of like that's what
everybody
Associates so that's the first thing
that comes up in Google if you [__]
search that stuff
so okay so let's talk a little bit about
this whole radar thing like where the
f-16s Apparently like chased okay yeah
this thing see if you dug up some more
about this I've heard you know
different sides of this we'll see
so uh the first report not so much uh
you know spaceships flying around or
anything like that the first thing that
is reported
um
was that they'd had a bunch of people
call in saying it's like well uh you
know a bunch of uh gender arms like cops
and stuff like that called in saying it
was like we'll just see these weird
lights in the sky
um it's like they kind of look like
stars but they're not the same color as
stars you know what I mean like they're
different colors like green and red and
stuff
so uh after they got a couple of those
reports they actually did send a couple
f-16s up there to check it out
now apparently according to the pilots
they said that the stuff like did kind
of disappear off the radar and like
moved up and down like super super fast
um and they said apparently a couple
times they also went into the ground
you know uh so there was that
um now the pilot said that it went the
reading said that it went into the
ground right right yeah because the
pilots the two F-16 that's not a good
set up there they said they didn't see
anything like in this guy it was just
like on the radar it just returns
right they just saw like this weird
thing on like on the radar
now
um
apparently like sobeps who were like I
said the the UFO people like that
published the thing about it they said
that uh and I think they repeated this
on the um unsolved mystery show was that
the radar locks they had got radar locks
on the targets like nine times
um that is apparently not the case they
said that there were only three radar
locks and when they analyzed it later
they found out that those three locks
were all on each other like on
like one clock in on each other you know
what I mean
um and honestly the other contacts that
they got they said they found out that
they were
um pretty much atmospheric interference
like you get um they call it brag
scattering
where it's like
um air density
uh you know it's the air density is like
different in little pockets and stuff
and it causes these weird like anomalies
uh they're pretty sure about that like
they've seen it lots of times they call
um you know it causes these weird Echoes
that they call Angels you know what I
mean
um so they the original report did
actually say that the three locks that
they had they were pretty much sure that
it was either on each other or it was
one of these like Angels things so they
weren't flying in a group
what do you mean well if the planes are
flying in a group how do they there were
only two of them there were only two
places if there are two planes aren't
they flying in a pair
how do they lock on I guess I'm just
saying that it's like this is what I
read they'll like don't ask me I'm just
saying that it's like
they said that it wasn't anything
unusual I like have to they just said
that they was not
that it was just either
air density anomalies or it was one
playing like clock I'd have to see a
real technical out in a technical Focus
because like I said so bad people that
really know they kind of came out and
said nine radar locks but they're like
that when they went back to the original
reports that wasn't what they reported
that it was only three and they
explained them all
explain them all no okay the original
the Air Force explained them all okay
because that's not what that one Air
Force General said
but see I don't know I'm just saying
that's what the original report said as
far as as far as I'm aware as far as I'm
more so it's inconclusive
I'm just saying that it's like I don't
you know I don't know I know this
Radars work
they can find other aircrafts and they
can shoot them down
guys that use them regularly understand
um radar returns you know and they they
know they you Ted they tend to know the
anomalies
if they were fooled at the time they
were either poorly trained
okay which I kind of maybe they were
poorly trained that's what I said that's
a total possibility yeah and just they
just you know because it's Belgium I
mean you know [__] they haven't been
in any wars lately at this time it was a
Cold War era or maybe that was like the
bee squad or they were tired or
something there could be like a million
different things like I said that's
there's a million other explanations
that you could go to before
extraterrestrials I would really have to
see something
amazing before I would jump to
extraterrestrials because there's a
million other things that it could be an
anomalies
there's a lot of radar and yeah but in
general Radars work and the guys that
use right but in general a lot of things
work but still like [__] up [__]
happens yeah and you don't know why but
there's not always a reason all right
I'm just saying I'm just gonna let Jenny
have that one
there's a lot of equipment that I used
that I knew that there was a a chance of
error
but I knew the errors when I saw
you know
but I don't know who these Pilots were
and I don't know this General
you know maybe he maybe just he bought
into it but I don't know I don't know
I'd have to know more about it that's
what I mean that's why I kind of feel
like a lot I'm not going to Discount the
case though well no I'm not either I'm
just saying that
because an army if they want an army if
they wanted to say we didn't see
anything they would just go in and they
would just put out a black propaganda
piece saying oh no it was just they
didn't know how to interpret the data
their their radar was malfunctioning
oh well then that means they need to
replace that radar system if the radar
system malfunctions and that means you
can't trust it in combat why is that in
service and then if they say oh well
we're not going to where I'm going to
change it
oh I
just know that yeah well yeah but see
you could say that too because then like
every time that like something comes to
a conclusion that you don't like you can
just say oh well they're just covering
it up well that's what they do well
that's what I mean like and I'm not
saying that doesn't happen yeah I'm just
saying that it's like yes anytime
anything happens that the authorities
don't like that threatens them they they
say it's not true that's just that's
just what they did right but that
doesn't necessarily it goes right but
that's why it's so difficult to get to
the bottom of stuff because it's like
yeah there are some motivations for
people in power to cover stuff up you
know I'm not saying there's not
cover-ups because there are but I'm just
saying that that doesn't necessarily
make it true that every time they say
that it's like oh well it was just like
radar anomalies that doesn't necessarily
mean that that's false either you know
what I'm saying so it's like you really
have to have
some kind of like objective uh evidence
about the [__] like what actually it was
too long about anybody it was too long
ago this is forgotten and no one's going
to go through that [__] again and then
the dudes that really know that radar
well that particular radar
uh are probably dead by now
because those dudes were in their 40s or
50s back then
yeah maybe and like it doesn't seem like
it but the early 90s was a very it was a
long time ago that was when I graduated
high school and that was a very locked
up so there's no way there's going to be
no way to know
yeah so like I said it's just like I
don't I'm not discounting that this [__]
happened like somebody didn't see some
weird [__] like maybe they did
I'm just saying one it probably wasn't
as impressive as they reported which you
know nothing ever is
um
but
I don't know I I just kind of feel like
I always fall down on the side of like
what is more likely
I kind of feel like it's always more
likely
that there was some kind of uh you know
technological fault or there was some
kind of like or people misperceive
things or something like that that's
always way more likely than positing
that extraterrestrials are visiting the
Earth because that's kind of like a
whole other thing that you have I mean
that's
that opens up like a whole other can of
worms I'm just gonna believe the
testimonies what those cops said those
cops said that they saw that [__] so but
see like I said we mentioned we talked
about this earlier when I [__] say
that witness reports yeah are and I'm
not saying I'm not [__] on people
that like say that this happened because
you know you shouldn't believe people
they're like you know experiences to an
extent but
you probably most of the time depending
on what it is you should probably get
like some backup on that because it's
just kind of like people can go back to
the beginning and they're not always
Liars it goes back to the beginning of
this [__] show
statistically crimes don't happen
statistically [__] atrocities don't
happen
that's the it is normal for atrocities
not to happen atrocities are unlikely
but people commit atrocities they do all
kinds well yeah and then there's [__]
witnesses that see it
and [__] sometimes they're not
believed but that did happen but like I
said that's why you can't go too far in
either direction because it's like you
know just because somebody comes out and
says hey I was like I'm kept captive by
somebody like eight people yeah like
that sounds crazy but that doesn't
necessarily mean that that's not true
because that does happen yes it's
unlikely but that doesn't mean that it's
impossible or that it doesn't happen so
like I said that's why it's always good
to kind of have corroborating evidence
that you can't just come right out the
gate and just necessarily
believe everything that people say just
on their word because like I said people
can lie they can be mistaken they can
remember things wrong this it's like a
lot of things that can happen
UFO [__] is pretty much always going to
be very elusive it's not going to be a
bunch of Cooperative corrupt well it's
kind of the same thing as we talk about
it with like Paranormal cases and ghost
cases it's like you know I don't
necessarily think all those people are
full of crap I just think that they're
interpreting things like maybe in a
framework
um
that I don't I'm not really sure how to
put this that it doesn't really but you
know they have a certain framework of
where they're how they're going to
interpret certain things that happen
that maybe if I was in the same
situation I would probably not interpret
things the same way that's all I'm gonna
say you know what I mean I guess
I know that a Japanese dude might be
flying in a damn cargo plane back in the
70s and see a gigantic [__]
spacecraft or he thinks he's a
spacecraft
and then it leaves there's no [__]
evidence at all right it's just what he
said right
nearly cost him his career just by
saying that
you know but maybe that did happen
right there but maybe not like there's
really no way of knowing because like I
said people's experiences are to an
extent very subjective
I have the feeling that uh just
based on [__]
if you're a person that spends a lot of
Time Out outdoors and out in the [__]
Woods and [__] like that you know I kind
of grew up
out there you're never going to see a
bear
unless you're out in the woods bears are
here they're taking the [__] on the side
of the house
okay but you may not believe bears
actually exist if you stayed in [__]
in the house all the time I think the
aliens are about the same same kind of
situation there's probably a lot there's
got to be lots of life in the galaxy and
some of them travel around and some of
them come by and visit and then they
just move on
and they've known about us for a long
time
and there's not going to be any evidence
they're not going to leave any evidence
behind
that's just how I think it's gonna going
to be so they might come down and look
at the plane and then [__] Zoom or
zoom off
and just some of the reports say just
the way they act is kind of odd you know
moving in patterns cross patterns and
circle patterns and then just leaving
like something that a child would do
it's like they're doing donuts on your
lawn yeah metaphorically so we were like
well why would they do that well they're
not human that's why they did that you
know it's like yeah why are you trying
to like impose you right yeah you're
human-central like yeah why didn't they
do this and that is because they're not
a human being
they may not they got their own [__]
reasons we don't know what they are I
think they're not biological it's some
it's some kind of extremely Advanced AI
probably a lot of times like the
monolith basically what you're talking
about
but reportedly [__] looks playful that
they do
yeah maybe they're just [__] with us
space squirrels
space squirrels yeah I just had like a
really funny mentality it's like little
squirrels like flat in the [__] you're
like little [__] squirrels flying up
a little [__] spacecraft yeah you
know what I mean all right so um are you
are you done talking about this topic
you seem like what is it done
I guess I'm done with my notes oh you
don't have the notes okay [__] so that's
pretty much a wrap then I guess yeah you
want to talk about something else oh I
might just have a little restroom
how many times is that
okay I didn't realize that the show was
over
usually he gets like uh really bored and
he's like what want to wander off
Ben says meteorites and satellites
crashing do count for a lot of UFO
sightings yeah
um
like I said I'm just kind of like I'm
not saying that there's not
extraterrestrials I'm not saying that
there's not life in the in the Galaxy or
in the larger you know I'm sure that
there is I mean
you know I'm a statistical person
statistically it's very likely that
there's probably life elsewhere in the
universe
whether it comes here
um that's a whole other question that's
two completely different things so it's
like I'm not really sure
and if all you have is just people
saying that they saw this that and the
other like if you have a bunch of people
saying they saw the same thing like
independently of one another yeah that's
you know that's more evidence in that
regard but you just have one person
saying it's like yeah you know I was on
a dark Road and like my car stopped and
like somebody like sucked me up into a
spacecraft and like you know probe my
butt or whatever it's just kind of like
I don't know I think it's much much more
likely that that person is just
imagining things or they dreamed
something or they're just making stuff
up for whatever reason or something like
that I'm always gonna like err on the
side of
what is statistically most likely you
know what I'm saying like depending on
what it is but I mean
stuff like Paranormal stuff alien stuff
ghosts stuff like that
that's considerably less likely than
other things like crime which actually
does happen quite often so it's like I'm
gonna give that a little bit more leeway
but
things like this I don't know I'm not
saying that people didn't see what they
saw I'm just saying that
do we know what that was we don't know
there's not like a lot of
other
Ben says Earth is like an Intergalactic
truck stop where different aliens from
across the Galaxy make pit stops there's
a Mojo mixing song about it oh my God I
love got these gays out there trying to
[__] check the prostate and [__]
Tom needs a prostate yeah yeah I don't
understand it do you really no do you
need me to stick it but now I'm [__]
here drinking alcohol bro
I'm gonna go to the restroom
um so Pokey
pokey's been having ass problems she's
[__] had her to her oh her anal
glands got messed up she's got impacted
he got impacted yeah poor little baby
it's okay so we've been trying to like
wash our butt and she is just like she's
fighting it she's like not happy about
it okay so uh I'm making something to
eat after this huh what you gonna make
well I got a bunch of uh Spanish rice
that yellow Spanish rice okay I got a
bunch of uh um Carnitas okay and um I'll
make a second remember the bowl remember
I made like a basketball I'll make that
you want two tortillas three
yeah we'll do that that sounds really
good actually yeah that sounds good good
shut it down Jim all right so as I
mentioned uh Friday we are probably
definitely not gonna do a side track
show on Friday because I have to work on
that day yeah which is a weird thing to
say nowadays and I'm gonna go to my
brother's house after that so I'm gonna
be in Daytona like all night but I kind
of feel like we'll probably do it
Saturday at some point
so I'll announce it like whenever we
decide to do it on Saturday I don't know
we're gonna be doing on Saturday but
we'll do a Sidetrack show on Saturday
instead of Friday so hopefully my bird
sent us 20 thank you man oh thank you
thanks thank you
did you get is it a super chat or is it
something like that because I'm kind of
behind what is that let me see
oh that's like um
is that cash app or I think especially
cash app or it's like I can't release it
or it might just be on Facebook yeah
okay we'll figure it out yeah but yeah
thank you very much anyway so yeah so um
probably be Saturday that we'll see you
guys again we'll try to do a side track
show on Saturday so thanks everybody for
dropping by talking about aliens this
evening and we will see you guys again
this weekend
good night